[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
buddy you want to watch Boris television
you could turn it on but you could stay
with us and watch the NBA Draft what's
good Adam the lef koe man in the
building this guy to my left the
Jonathan Wasserman the NBA Draft expert
he gets it done do you see the shirt it
is not the fourth member of the migos it
is Terry Rozier are the Boston Celtics
that took down my Sixers and Howard Beck
the greatest NBA writer in the history
of roundball James Naismith once said
Howard Beck he could write my
bibliography yes none of that sentence
made sense but that's what we do here
click share click like have a good time
we're gonna break down the draft but
first I've actually known Terry for a
really long time and we kind of found
something and we want to show our
relationship together so if we could
really quickly me and Terry from way
back in the day Shaker Heights point
guard Terry Rozier always had the talent
and local respect but never the major
attention that was until the LeBron
James skill Academy this past summer
just days Terry began receiving offers
from big-time universities and getting
challenged by Cleveland's best players
even if I'm not playing against the best
is gotta play hard got flavor to age no
matter what do you realize how crazy
people Louisville are about basketball
oh yeah just me I can feel it when I
went down here for a visit it shocked me
like some people that was in the stands
like just notice who I was it's not a
couple jerseys and stuff so it was nice
but they like diehard fans
oh one I look ridiculous
too though ain't no based on the voice
my gut you're right I was a very thick
Louisville sports anchor at that time
it's not just us though okay I know us
four will be great we're gonna break
down every pic even though apparently
watch bomb the giraffe and gave the
first six picks out let me take you
around we have two studs that if you
haven't seen them on Instagram live
you're gonna see them now master and
June they're gonna be manning social
media bringing us the memes the reaction
what do you guys got going on over there
well we've got a woge bomber early as
you mentioned the first six picks have
been announced poach about about four
hours ago
the audrey end is going to the suns at
number one the Sacramento Kings are
taking Marvin Begley Jr number two the
Atlanta Hawks are taking Luca Dodge and
number three the the Grizzlies are
taking Jerry Jackson jr. at number four
the Mavericks are taking mo Bamba number
five and a magic or tricking Trey Young
at number six so that's all we've got
for you so far we're gonna bring you
more from the internet and all the
reaction forwards what do you think
master it seems the load is also talking
about Michael Porter Jr could slide
seems like he's had some back issues
going in obviously that that hampered
his career in college we'll see how he
does I'm excited man I think's gonna be
really fun to Rev usually I tune out of
the NBA Draft after like picks seven yes
John best Lee goes up like it just at
that point it's just like it's not
interesting anymore so I think this will
be a much much more interesting draft
leading up to the pick 20 pick 25 so and
I'm sure is Wasserman knows it's a much
deeper draft on what you're used to in
customs scene so should be a good time
and I'm excited got the Hennessy on deck
nice say that we posting memes mean
straight up comments we got everything
for you all right awesome
well yeah I'll tell you what it's one of
two things are gonna happen either we
already know the top six picks were
which is wrong and both of those things
could be entertaining well there's
another possibility too of course which
is that there are teams that are still
trying to move up just got a text a
second ago the Bulls are trying to move
up to get mo Bamba and that won't be the
last one of these that we're going to
hear you know this is
been all along perceived as a fluid
draft not only the bodies where they
could go but the teams because so many
teams were eager to move up to get some
of these guys some teams wanted to move
down because they weren't enamored
enough or like somebody that they knew
they could get a few pics later so I
mean I'm sure Johnny wasa started to
like I think all the smoke in the world
maybe nothing happens but there's a lot
of chatter still going on awesome so I
just got a dig in my ear which means the
pic is in so we're gonna go to our pick
experts master in June to tell us if
indeed ate and went one he's gonna
announce all the picks because I am NOT
good with pronunciation with names
takeaway so officially the Phoenix Suns
have taken DeAndre Aiden number one
overall from Arizona shocking stunner
all right so here's how it's gonna work
I am gonna be doing videos for the
Bleacher Report app with Johnny wass
what we're gonna do is he's gonna break
down if the value is right for that
player at that pick and then also who is
this guy I'm gonna lay this on out for
you
Howard Beck has studied a lot this is
Johnny Wasa's job he's the Guru me and
Terry
we don't really know all these guys so
we're gonna listen to what wass has to
say and then to see if it's actually a
good pick but all these videos will be
available in the BR app so we're gonna
show you we're gonna break down right
now we're gonna do the first pick
DeAndre eight and going number one to
the Phoenix Suns who lost you feeling
good I'm feeling excellent good I'm
pumped for Anthony what is your grade
for this pick gonna be I'm going a - hey
don't don't give the reason yet they
just needed it for the graphic yeah I
know I got you excited I want to get
started already alright but I know he's
not your number one Luca was your number
one Luca was my number one is my number
one but Aiden at the same time is a very
good prospect the Suns have their center
of the future how much do you think it
mattered that he went to Arizona and
that he's from Arizona it matters I mean
he's playing in their backyard the owner
is very familiar with him the coaching
staff is very familiar with him the fact
that he fits a need and has all that
number one overall upside that also is
the most important thing for Phoenix
awesome all right let's do this video
DeAndre eight into the Phoenix Suns
you'll see it
Beck and then my weird face and then his
beautiful face and we'll break it down
what's up
by the way comment on Facebook comment
on YouTube master in June we'll be
checking for all the comments first pick
of the draft is in Phoenix tons they
stay local DeAndre and the big man with
big potential what do you think of Aten
as the first pick in the strip it wasn't
number one on my board so naturally I
don't love it at the same time we're
talking about a franchise type Center
this is a 19 year old in a 30 year olds
body 7 feet 2 50 75 wingspan athletic
mobile skilled in the post but it can
also stretch you out from behind the arc
as a nice touch from the elbows
developing three-point range
an aggressive dominant rebounder around
that low block so very physical presence
who also has some finesse to his game
and what the NBA wants now is big guys
who can step away from the basket that's
something agent showed in his freshman
year at Arizona all right so first pick
in the draft you said dongok was gonna
be your number one
what grade though do you give for 18 at
that time so we knock him down a little
bit to an a-minus nothing wrong with an
a-minus he's still gonna be a 20 and 10
guy every single night you may make a
couple all-star teams the question is is
he gonna be a stats over wins guy I'm
not sure but definitely somebody that
Phoenix can feature in their half-court
with Devin Booker they now have to go to
players and two cornerstones that they
could Bank on for the next decade that
really is the question
well Devin Booker stay now that Aten is
in the fold Phoenix Suns first pick in
the draft
DeAndre from Arizona
okay so that's what we call one take
Timmy because loss is a baller and I
just ride his coattails all right let's
go to Terry you saw his highlights
that's a huge man and you know what
Devin Booker is capable of could that be
a dynamic duo that you guys could face
in the season yeah I mean it's always
good when you got a guy that can shoot
the lights out from the three-point line
and Devin Booker is great crazy shots
full of sofas that plays amazing then
you got a got it they just drive did
DeAndre who was a force inside so I
don't think of his highlights I'm he's
pretty good Duncan to everybody so you
know get out this way you know this way
but uh it was just good to have a
presence inside and in the guy that that
can do two things outside he knows it
always they always complement each other
so that's too good that's good I think
Howard it seems like there was some
people that thought Aten was number one
and that some people thought that Danzig
was number one what did you hear from
people that you talked to in the NBA
about who like two more well I mean I
think it just depended obviously on the
front office and how they evaluated
these guys and whether you believe that
Aten is really the right kind of big man
for today's NBA game that is the
question you know guys who can score
around the basket okay great but the
offensive minded center the go-to type
five man is outdated in today's NBA now
you can always use a guy whose can score
efficiently there and the Sun certainly
needs some balance to that offense being
able to have a guy who that who Devin
Booker can play off of is important but
I think a lot of people were more
enamored as Jonathan Wasserman was of
dodges all-around skillset and today's
NBA game is so much more about having a
bunch of guys who are like Terry's
teammates bunch of guys in that six
seven two six nine range who are all
long range II can switch defensive
assignments and in dantos case you know
forget the defense for a moment handles
the ball shoots the ball makes plays I
think his versatility to me I think is
more attractive than what Aten might be
able to do and you need rim protection
at that position yeah there are
questions about whether DeAndre Tain's
going to be that guy
gotcha what do you is there is a league
change it can you feel it
no the league is definitely changes the
guys is they got a lot of small
positions
you know playing small ball but my
question is the Phoenix Suns is you got
a lot of young guys on that team so
obviously it helps when yeah you got
them defensive presence but is he gonna
really get the ball he's going to man
the ball get the ball on offense they
don't make sure you get the ball offense
for him to be a force inside I don't
know question I mean he wants the ball
he's an aggressive scorer
he called himself Shaq and Devin Booker
the next Kobe so he's very confident in
himself the big question with Aten is
can you protect the basket if you're a
center and you're the center piece of a
team you need to be able to protect the
rim in today's NBA and I don't know if
he could do it at the highest level all
right so the first pick is in it was
indeed DeAndre a little bit of questions
about defense a little bit of questions
if he's gonna be able to score at that
level but now let's go to our dynamic
duo it's rush hour for its master in
June with the second pick of the draft
go ahead Lee things are ticking Marvin
Begley the third according to mark Stein
a guy obviously went to Duke and this
has been kind of expected from what the
reports been Alaska absence wanted to
have been expected but Mark Steyn man
he's killing right on Twitter he just
had another tweet the Mavericks are
closing in on a trade for Luca Don
chicken sources we Howard you hear my
surprise of the night here with the
Dallas Mavericks
seeing the same thing that master is
apparently this is gonna be a trade
between the Hawks and the Mavericks the
Hawks are selecting Don touch for the
Mavericks Oh according to Mark Steyn of
the New York Times so that's interesting
you see right there that Dallas and I
think we were talking about this earlier
that that was a team that clearly
thought that Dantas was the player in
this draft and so it'll be trusting to
see what's changing hands in this deal
the Mavericks have been high on Don
judge all year they had a number one on
their board they're gonna get him at
number three after trading up we'll see
what it cost them sure but that's
terrific value for them I could be a
really interesting cool fit with Dennis
Smith jr. in the backcourt alright so
first what we're gonna do is we're gonna
break down Bagley going to the Kings at
number two then we'll dive a little bit
further into that trade for dhansak who
apparently will be drafted at three and
then
to the maths with a 5th pick so me and
wasps will now be doing the Kings
selecting Marvin Bagley Sacramento Kings
where are they gonna go they just took
to Aaron Fox and they pair him up with
Marvin Bagley out of Duke this kid puts
up 20 and 10 and before he even wakes up
so what do you think of them as the
second pick of the dress and like you
said he's a walking double-double as the
second pick in the draft he would not be
my second pick in the draft in fact I
had him number 6 on my final big board
but let's get to the positives about
Bagley
he's 611 he's one of the best athletes
in the draft has a quick first step a
quick second jump an animal under the
board's and he could face you up like a
611 guy and take you off the dribble and
attack showed some three-point range
shot around 38% from downtown and just a
very versatile offensive player the big
questions are with his defense he lacks
length and he's not a big passer so it's
gonna take him a little bit of time I
think I don't think they're gonna
feature him right away and it would help
if he had veterans around him but in
terms of upside it's tough to argue with
what they saw what the Kings saw with
Marvin back are you said that you had
him as your sixth pick not the second so
what does that mean for the grade from
Marvin Bagley I give it to be I thought
this was a great opportunity to take
Dodgers they need a winner and I think
this was again not the greatest fit for
Bagley who would have benefited from
going to a team with veterans that could
set the table for him because I think he
struggles a bit to create his own shot
and I wonder how he's gonna develop on a
team with the Kings who pretty much you
know are focused on the Aaron Fox and
Buddy hield so he's gonna have some
trouble get getting going early on and
plus the defensive concerns so I do have
question marks about him but again I
think he's gonna be a guy who gives you
18 and 10 but is the impact there and
how much does he hurt you want defense
needed a lot of help of that frontcourt
you talked about all the guys the
backcourt Kings are open that Bagley is
the guy that can score a lot on the low
post for them for years to come
all right so how are what do you what
does that mean oh we have a trade it's
official the trade is official he has
official how Lucas going to the mass
let's get this hat on baby my man is out
here doing work Dallas baby we back he
master has been a mouse fan for four
minutes now hey man he's been the best
four minutes of my life oh oh oh yeah
let's look Bagley to the Kings wasps
just broke it down the dodge ik trade
taking me kind of into what you're here
and how or what you think about it well
it's fascinating because of according to
again according to mark Stein from the
New York Times there is no there no
players changing hands here future pick
from Dallas also going to Atlanta so
it's just a swap of the three and the
five and then a future pick what I love
about this is obviously this this great
symmetry that twenty years later the
team that got Dirk Nowitzki that really
you know jump-started the International
influx into the NBA and got Dirk
acclimated and grew him into a superstar
in this league
maybe the best international player ever
they've got Luca now and Dirk is still
there for at least another season I
think that mentorship could be really
important and obviously a franchise that
knows how to to kind of acclimate a
player coming over from Europe and I
think Luke is actually ahead of the game
I think he speaks more English already
now than Dirk did as a rookie alright so
I guess we're giving a grade for the
Mavericks going up again and what Grady
gonna give present a plus this was the
top player on my board not only do I
love the upside and and Don teaches
potential in the NBA and his fit the NBA
but I love his fit with the Dallas
Mavericks next to Dennis Smith Jr who
was a guy who attacks puts pressure on
the basket he's a scorer dodge it's more
of a do-it-all jack-of-all-trades
playmaker shooter more of an east-west
not a north-south guy the way Dennis
Smith jr. is and doesn't have that Smith
like bounce and athleticism but he
thinks the game he's really smart I
really loved it before we do this video
I have a question for you
I remember when Chris tops got drafted
by the Knicks and he got booed because
there was this perception that like
foreign players are soft I want to know
from the NBA perspective let's say the
Celtics draft a foreign guy are you like
man some Italian guys coming in like
what is your take on that
no I mean obviously we're gonna be
excited
we have no take on the guys or we we
have no yeah we're not judging no guys
overseas yeah we got a guy from Prince
we know it's just interesting just to
see when you come in you know how I
adjust obviously with the language and
things like that learning to play like
when you're speaking a different
language than a teammate we don't have
we don't have guys that are okay yeah
Gershon oh he speaks our language it was
actually funny he's actually the jokes
around and stuff like that but we we
have had that problem but I'm pretty
sure is interested for every team when
they get a guy like that just to see how
I would imagine all right now we're
gonna do so dodge ik as a third pick
but then traded to the Mavericks top
player losses board let's do the video a
plus he gave an A plus
this is his guy yeah well you get to
watch this highlights alright so the
third pick in the draft it was the
Falcons but it's then traded to the
Mavericks Luca dhansak your top player
on your board what I said that Lana
Falcons did Dan let's do it again
Terry's over here laughing :
yeah I'm still an NFL mode good answer
right here
he called me all right away alright
Terry I'm gonna get you later no
opponent I'm gonna play that game
all right so the third pick in the draft
went to the Atlanta Hawks
but then traded to the Dallas Mavericks
and it's Luka John chick the number one
player on your board the value for the
fifth team to get this guy's got to be
crazy yeah eight plus for me I mean this
is the MVP of your league usually it's a
big deal when a nineteen-year-old gets a
minutes in your league he was the best
player in your league this past summer
year a basket he beat up on porzingis
and lafayette he beat up on Spain and
the Gasol's and Hernan Gomez brothers
and Ricky Rubio he did it at 18 years
old Wow he's one of the most dominant
players overseas and he's a teenager six
eight size powerful frame a playmaker
very great great vision and a knockdown
shooter at least becoming a knockdown
shooter and just a do-it-all versatile
guy really competitive really tough he's
a guy who may not value with 20 points a
game but his impact is really felt with
his decision-making his ability to
control the pace of the game alright so
give you a grade one more time but also
what kind of a career do you expect
didn't have and acted he lasts until now
well number three so obviously there was
a lot of upside tied to guys like a
tandem Bagley those guys are more
athletic there was some were a little
bit hesitant I'm Don touch because he
doesn't have that bounce he doesn't have
those high light dunks he's not gonna
blow by you but he changed his speeds
really well he's highly skilled off the
dribble and again like I mentioned
before his vision he makes players
better he's an A+ pick in this draft at
number one at number three the Mavericks
got another franchise player to pair
with Dennis Smith junior that backcourt
now covers it all man look at Don Jake
the Mavericks
as our own Howard Beck said to be able
to transition from Nowitzki to dhansak
it's a beautiful thing Mark Cuban has to
be over the moon at Lucca in the first
round
Atlanta Falcons I'm such a goof alright
so now we're gonna move on to the
Grizzlies where a lot of people thought
this is kind of where the giraffe could
change where the Mavericks have already
jumped up
what are we kind of expecting here
you're either of you guys hearing
anything with the Grizz I know a lot of
teams are calling the question is our
team's gonna take back Chandler Parsons
fat contract and I don't think they're
going to but there's definitely gonna be
a lot of phone calls there have been all
day there happen all week who do you
think the prized possession is as a
chair in Jackson jr. I think Muhammad
bomba jaren Jackson Jr those are
probably the two big names right now who
teams would be looking to trade off for
those are two defensive center pieces
and that could really change the
identity of a franchise and also just
from a media perspective Mark Steyn is
gonna be the one breaking all the news
tonight right because he's like the only
person not connected to the NBA well you
know caveat on that though what the
media partners of the league agreed to
or supposedly agreed to with not the tip
picks nothing to do with the trades
though so watch Stein everybody
everyone's been on the Atlanta Dallas
swap now Stein had at first but that's
going to be unfolding so the trades
we'll hear about but the pic tipping
other than the six picks that were
broken by woods and others four hours
ago yeah we'll see if that holds up or
or not but in the meantime
yeah Memphis speaking of trades that's
the one that I think we came into the
night the most intrigued by because they
have been really eager to try to package
the fourth pick with Chandler Parsons
contract the Knicks have been among the
teams that were heavily pursuing one you
know some iteration of that kind of deal
and there are teams that'll be willing
to do it you swallow that contract and
you're getting a crack at at you know
whoever it may be if you're in love with
Bamba and that's your guy you can get
him maybe it's worth taking on the two
years of Parsons did master in June did
you guys see what the trade was forward
you see that player yeah it's a future
first actually but no players involved
no players involved number three number
five or swap but I will say this man
huevo was a big fan of this trade bro
tre young to the Hawks Atlanta's own
splash bro the cultures behind you
hashtag that's what we need he loves it
then Smith juniors approving of the tray
to for Luca going to the mass we'll see
it held up that's the thing I
I'm getting right now on my BR app which
have you going the VR app that the the
Matt the fount of the Hawks excuse me or
going to trade excuse me
select Trey young and then send him to
Atlanta he was the one that the me goes
were like yo draft this guy the kid from
Oklahoma I'm sure you've seen this guy
but Trey young going that early he's
big-time led the country and scoring
assists that doesn't happen it takes
over games this is a guy that Atlanta
needed they Dennis Schroder is not you
know the franchise guy that you can lean
on for the next ten years young there's
some risk tied to young he plays below
the rim he's skinny and he needed that
green light you'll Oklahoma that he's
not gonna have but we'll see what
happens he's clearly a talented player
alright so let's go to master in June
with some information on the next pick
number four so according to woge and
Sean's rania Memphis is selecting jaren
Jackson junior with the number one for
overall pick so we've got pretty much
one through five already locked in right
now it's been a great draft so four
minutes we really interesting
alright so Terry do you like playing in
Memphis like when you go there as have
fun it's not super fun some places
that's way better than Memphis like
you're in Memphis so it's not really
nothing what are the play they have some
nice to have some nice spots to eat at I
was gonna say the bar feels really real
but like what are the spots like are you
excited to play the Heat the Lakers I
love planning he I love going to LA I
Love New York New York one of my
favorite NBA sees I go shopping and you
tell Anna hoochie everything yeah you
know I love Atlanta he used to you know
just nice and then on the opposite side
Memphis and who else would you not like
to go to Memphis I would say Cleveland
if I went from there well it's a lot
Minister no I minnesota's 500 what do
you got for us Howard I've got Orlando
Magic are going to be selecting mo Bamba
who expect that any minute now
damn Howard Beck breaking news mo Baba
all right so where did Jared Jackson so
me and Terry are gonna learn right now
from Jonathan Wasserman this is a
Terry that everyone talks about has like
unlimited potential you feel that way
too
yeah he's a potential guy not a stats
guy but a potential guy what grade are
you giving this pick this isn't a for me
he was number two on my board coming in
perfect all right so we're ready for
this pick we're gonna do this now
jaren Jackson a michigan state he's
going to Terry's favorite MBA city
Memphis it's kids gonna just get stocked
up on barbecue okay and then so mo baba
where'd you get that from
who told you again we're getting my
phone what is what is it how do you work
sources Howard Beck because like I can't
compensate a question for a draft show
Adam really do you have sources to me
and Terry the only guys up here without
sources on you are you Terrence got some
sources turns got old are you talking to
I noted 27 pick I know who is going to
me you know who the Celtics are taken
yeah I don't believe any of the guys
gonna be on the board when they when
they get there I'm that y'all figure it
out no I appreciate you Terry okay all
right let's do it
fourth pick Memphis Grizzlies a lot of
people were talking about maybe they
trade this speck they stand pat jaren
Jackson junior the number two guy on
your board why was he so high all about
potential of 611 size 247 5 wingspan he
was the only player in the country to
block 3 shots in fewer than 25 minutes
per game but he also knocked down two 3s
for 40 minutes he stretches you out from
downtown and then he protects the rim at
an elite level later in the season he
showed signs of being able to face the
basket and attack a closeout as we saw
in the highlights he can score around
the basket synergy Sports had them in
the 98th percentile on post ups so he
covers pretty much every angle you want
from a big man in today's NBA
particularly defense he's the type of
guy who the block shots and then switch
around the perimeter and pick and roll
game and guard your wings guard your
ball handlers he covers it all he may
not be ready right now but three years
from now he's still gonna be 21 years
old I was gonna say he's 18 years old
and he's being drafted that's insane
what is your grade for getting him
before
I give him in them an eight I mean this
is the like I said before this is this
the second guy on my board it's all
about upsides with him and his fit in
today's League is just so perfect you
look at that Memphis roster they need
young guys I mean they've been relying
on Gasol and Conley for so long they
need somebody who build around I think
he's the type of guy Jackson who could
play the for next took a saw I saw was a
big guy D in big body inside
Jackson more nimble can play around the
perimeter I think eventually he replaces
Gasol in the middle but for now I think
they fit together in the frontcourt
awesome jaren Jackson the future of the
Memphis Grizzlies there's no guards
Terry all I'm seeing is big guys going
the guards are coming
oh are they that coming coming on what
you guys I saw you watching his
highlights what you think six 11 and 18
okay you can't you can't pass that up
how old were you when you got drafted I
was Wendy could you imagine being 18
three years I couldn't imagine I was
crazy yeah you have an advantage were
you gonna ask him a question
no okay you're pointing it I probably
wasn't forgotten Howard you got
something else for us no it was just the
reports are now that it is in fact Bamba
but we knew that Howard back is just all
over it so Trey Young is going to
Atlanta we were joking before if felucca
went to Atlanta it would be like an odd
fit Trey young already like getting
shout out by quavo and the me goes him
what do you think about him in Atlantic
is this is the this is the prime time
guy that all the shoe companies were
fighting over I'm seeing them getting
advertisements all over he is like the
young sparkling face I'm curious your
grade for this pick but also your guys
take on what you think from them I'll
give you a good a negatory
I'll give it a b-plus I'm gonna be the
tough teacher here listen I'm a big tray
young fan you know he took a lot of
slack during the year for being a ball
hog he took how many shots a game one
Brodie game he took like 30-something
shots but the guy can create offense and
I think that's very valuable in today's
league give him the ball give him a ball
screen he's gonna create shots whether
it's for him or himself when we saw he's
got that deep ring
118 threes this year there and you could
put in when he's when he's guards so
he's going to generate offense the
question is how efficiently can he do so
given his physical tools and lack of
athleticism I think the only thing he
didn't do great and I think master is
you and could show this maybe once we
get done this pick a lot of people I
know are getting him for the the suit
that he wore today super shorts you guys
think about that style I perceive rock
with it man you gotta have enough
confidence you can have a sway you gotta
have a demeanor to rock with there I
rock with the look he was having them
draymond Green little puke green or the
blue shorts Tigers were one time 2sp
last year I didn't ride with those but
this color I think it works
not sure if I'm a big shorts with suits
fan I think we should keep the pants at
length I mean if you have a star on a
conference to do I think a look at all
sure young yeah are you doing this thing
I feel like if LeBron had actually won
Game one and then walked off with the
shorts with the suit I think would have
been much it we know that it now try you
let's go in Atlanta though he's gonna
fit right in bro they dressed really
weird over there trying for the culture
are we so what were you saying you think
you know what did you think about the
shorts suit I like it I'm all about
fashion I'm all about I'm not like
Russell Westbrook crazy with the fashion
but you know I'm all about put your neck
out there having fun with it uh nobody
else had the suit short so why not be
different when other NBA players see
what Russell Westbrook wears do you guys
like are you in the locker room like
showing each other pictures like this
guy's crazy one of the ripped holes and
stuff like that now we don't share
amongst each other well at least our
locker rooms don't but I think we all
see is like like it's not so much it's
like and it's like it looks weird but
it's just like it's just crazy and me
you just go that's for us yeah just
Russell yes I even seen you know for the
you know for the last couple years it's
just like that's just what he do so it's
just like you're used to it by now it's
just like what he's gonna wear next I
love it I think it's dope
all right let's do this pick Trey young
going to Atlanta with the fifth pick we
already know it's great let's make some
money
after a trade Atlanta getting Trey young
the primetime score out of Oklahoma I
mean he led the nation and everything
what do you think about getting him at
five I think it's good value I think
this is where he should have gone five
six that range
like you said leads the country in
scoring assists nobody does that and he
did it when every single defense that he
faced knew that this was the guy he had
to stop so and he did without much
support at Oklahoma his four other
teammates let's be honest they stunk and
he was just a very skilled as you see he
shoots with range from an everywhere
confidence and once he sees the ball and
go in a couple times it's gonna continue
to fall I think his biggest strength is
his ability to create offense and pass
he's got great vision terrific in the
pick-and-roll game breaks down defenses
kicks it out to shooters he's gonna get
your guys open shots the question is
Atlanta do they have anyone to make him
and so I worry a little bit that the
same thing that happened to him at in
Oklahoma down the stretch team defense
is focused in on him and he struggled
with efficiency is the same thing going
to happen in Atlanta he doesn't have
many veterans or scores around him to
play off what Grady given them and what
kind of rookie year do you think he is
I'm giving him a b-plus because he was
my number one point guard in the board
and I don't trust Dennis Schroder and
apparently they don't either I'd imagine
he's out of there sometime soon but
again they needed to they needed to
start somewhere fresh showed a young
brings a new face to the franchise a guy
who's gonna generate offense an exciting
young player to pair with John Collins
who is gonna catch a lot of lobs now
awesome Trey young the new face of the
franchise for Atlanta we'll see if he's
hitting those bombs down south in his
work he sees
all right Howard let me get your your
review of the top five thus far and if
you have any news please no no no news
actually real quick entre young I mean
this is interesting because you know to
Jonny's point about deadish Reuter you
have a new administration there Travis
lank starting his second full season as
GM you've got a new coach and Lloyd
Pierce who's first time head coach
coming over from the Phillies staff and
now you've got maybe the new face of
their franchise I mean I don't know who
that is right now this is a franchise
desperately in search of an identity
there are a lot of young pieces there
Turin Prince you know baseboards getting
up there but John Collins another young
guy they're trying to find somewhere in
this mix that that core group that can
grow together right and you know is it
straight like Boston has exactly but
it's Trey young that guy you know I
don't know you know again to Johnny
watch this point defenses are focusing
on I mean he's still leading the country
in scoring then the NBA defense is gonna
be focusing on him and Terry Rozier is
not gonna letting him get that shot off
you guys I mean you know are you gonna
be trapping this guy I mean if he's the
only offensive weapon on that team
you're you're all in on just like
shutting him down right we're not
trapping all rookie I'll tell you that
right now but notes it says his credit
when you can shoot the ball like that it
opens up a lot of things like you said
you mentioned his guys that he was
playing with in college it's gonna be
better day you know he's in the league
now he's playing with guys like Conor
you could throw - whoo - I think he's
gonna get a lot of tension when you can
shoot from deep and you could do things
he could do was his a what his ability
to shoot it opens up a lot of guys like
Torian Prince College so it's gonna be
interesting but uh you know we're not
done what seeman not doing alright so
let me read you Wasa's comparison and
you tell me what you think he called him
a poor man Steph Curry and an Isaiah
Thomas type what do you think which I
think it sums the the one that used to
be on your team right yeah yeah not I
got in trouble for acts of that question
one time which Isaiah Thomas if people
blew it up but uh you know it's two
hours a Thomas yeah no I think that was
a fair question man
poor women hurry we're gonna scurry
it's almost I kind of don't agree with
that why because you haven't played a
game in the NBA yeah oh so you don't
like comparing rookies to actual pros no
what was your comparison for Terry
Rozier do you remember no it's true
blessing where my binds too far away but
I'll bet I was I failed my evaluation on
Terry Rozier I think a lot of people I
owe you an apology
yes I've actually been waiting for this
a long time Terry he's been waiting for
this moment he wants to apologize to
this is this has been this has been
weighing on me for a long time I brought
I brought it by the way oh my god said
Balaji you don't accept ologies not
really wait what do you do you just want
to hold the grudge for the rest of your
life I just want to keep making you go
back on that apology that's you alright
so we have a gap here right can I do
this Johnny wass you good can I hide in
the table all right so I print out Terry
I printed out some of the grades that
you got from from back when you were
drafted
Chad Ford from ESPN at that time gave
you gave the Celtics of B overall that
was including you because you were that
they're the top pick draft net was a B
USA today b cbsb - jonathan Wasserman C
oh I told you I was no but all right so
but here's what I want to know now
Terry's points per game yeah you're
right three years in and one of the
things we always talk about on draft
night is we start giving out grades is
that yeah we don't really know who these
guys are like it takes development you
took a few years to breakthrough in an
opportunity at sort of that you know
environment development you've been
working hard on your game obviously all
along so the things that Johnny was
anybody else might have flagged three
years ago were they valid at the time
and this was just a matter of growth or
do people just like not get you I think
it plays a part of who would not gave me
me coming out of college and you know
I'm playing the one in the two and then
I come I get drafted by the Stokes who
has a lot of guards already so guys
probably was like how hot is gonna work
it was a big part of it it played a part
in the grade and stuff like that but you
know I'm a guy that's gone always
working and fine he's fine his room so
make it work no matter where I'm at and
you know a lot of guys can't see that so
you can't you can't get mad at him for
that I stuff for him I don't want a kiss
of poverty
now just
you know I just you stay patient I stay
patiently I'll play under guys like
Isiah Thomas and Kyrie Irving so I was
fortunate and you know I just I took a
lot of things I seen him out he I they
study the game and with things they did
and I ran with it you know you get the
opportunity to come knocking at your
door a lot of you young guys you gotta
take advantage another pick in we do
have another pick but you want to say
one last thing I was wrong
I'll say again that's not good yeah a
big time that's big time I give you an
a-plus I don't make greats that's why
it's great all right we got another pick
in I think just one the Howard Beck
already broke but a master June let's
see your beautiful faces so Chicago so
Moe Bombay is officially going to the
Orlando Magic at first broken by Howard
back and I will mention this comment by
rapper Vince staples Muhammad Bamba is
wearing that American Gangster
suit-and-tie first-ballot Hall of Fame
confirmed
I think the Bulls pick already though we
do have the bullsháá cago zeroing in on
Wendell Carter jr. with the seventh
overall pick according to woge I just
want to point out ESPN said that they
were gonna be tipping the pixel I shout
to vote for saying zeroing in in order
to I like we see you going to the
loophole see what I'm thinking a tennis
is basically about choosing you
I like that uh that Joon lifted up a
closed water bottle respect respect that
was great alright so we're gonna do ba
Baba to the magic who I feel like they
already have this player version so
let's do mobile about you guys ready all
right awesome
one of the most interesting pics in this
draft mo Bamba out of Texas his Reach is
crazy his shot looks amazing from the
outside and I feel like you actually had
him going around number four so six to
the matching is pretty darn good good
value yeah he was the best player on my
board so you know props to them for
overlooking the fact that maybe he
doesn't fit their franchise right now
but they took the best player available
so you know I respect that I respect
that strategy a seven-ten wingspan it's
never come around before it has the
potential to you know fuel some
unbelievable rim protection oh my gosh
and obviously the easy baskets that come
with it as a lob capture and just a
simple finisher but we saw flashes at
Texas
this guy has nice touch from outside an
improving stroke I think better than
what he showed to Texas and he's got a
post game but really again the appeal to
Bamba is his rim protection he can
change the game he could shrink the rim
that he's defending I have never seen a
710 wingspan that's nearly eight feet
that's crazy I want to know your grade
but I also want you to comment on this
guy's intelligence because III think
that needs to be explained to people I
give the grade in a and I've said this
to you before he's the most intelligent
prospect I've scouted I've listened to
since I've been doing this with bleacher
report just wanders jaylen Braun
everyone said it was too smart for the
NBA Jalen Brad is a bright dude Bamba is
on just another level up and just it
gets everything and I think that's
really gonna help him adjust once he
gets to the next level he's got to bulk
up a little bit obviously you can see
the big shoulders man those shoulders
could easily handle some bulls got the
potential to add some some weight but so
you like this for the magic I like it
the question is what did they do next
because they can't play blue Civic and
Aaron Gordon and Jonathan Isaac all at
the same time particularly in the NBA
where everyone's going small so Anna
roster change is gonna have to come but
Steve Clifford new coach defensive
oriented coach now he has his rim
protector to build around throw-in Isaac
who plays both multiple positions Gordon
is a restricted free agent but assuming
they bring him back he could play the
three for I don't know what it means
proposed to Fitch but they have a nice
defensive core to start building with
all right mo bomb of the picked for them
magic at number six I see our guide Nick
big magic fed losing his mind I should
you Orlando fans mo Baba
the guy at seis that was Spanish seis 6
no I'm good all right so if Wendell
Carter I'm seeing that he is going to be
the guy
I love Wendell Carter's draft outfit it
was very Wakanda he had like the sash
with the green and the leopard print if
you guys have them on your desktop when
I throw that up I'd love to see it
alright so Wendell Carter what greater
unity of that for the Bulls at 70 plus B
plus what do you know about this guy
Beck we still talking about Carter Obama
whoever you want to talk about for real
well let's talk about bomba for a second
actually because you there were Lando
magic when it was time to like you know
chart out okay what do they need I just
put one word everything this is a team
again new administration new front
office it took over a year ago and
they're just now starting to kind of try
to figure out you know who's staying
who's going they they shipped out Alfred
Payton this this roster it's not quite a
blank slate but it's it's blank slate
ish and yabuta [ __ ] is I think probably
not long for I think he's Orlando but
you know mo Bamba is gonna take some
time to grow into the NBA game so
they'll they'll have it have some
overlap there but his personality his
intelligence as well as his obviously
his on court presence and his ability to
be a difference maker defensively I
think this is a guy that that Orlando
can fall in love with I mean that's it
that's a team that has not had anybody
in a city of a fanbase that really isn't
anybody to embrace in a while since
before Dwight Howard turned out everyone
and ever since then it's been kind of
wandering in the desert and mo Bamba the
personality I guess you can't
underestimate the brightness of his
personality and his just is intelligence
the ability to bring in the fans with
that as well like charisma matters too
yes this is an entertainment vehicle as
well as a sport man I love the hater
Terkel ooh Rashard Lewis magic with
Dwight Howard that was also alright
master in June what do you got for us
well yeah I mean we'll go back to window
Carter's unit for just a quick minute
because
Vince staples it seems like he's gonna
be tween throughout the rest of the day
with all the Gucci he's got he's got
more couch eating terry rozier does
right now Vince staples says Wendell
Carter jr. will now be referred to amigo
from here on out and we've got another
pic in according to woge Cleveland
prefers Conn Sexton with the number
eight oh he seems to prefer now we're
gonna bring this Authority the source
out so yeah all right so we've got
zeroed in and preferred from whoa chart
we're gonna do Wendell Carter you kind
of predicted this earlier today going to
the Bulls they're at seven makes sense
based on Porter but I think we're ready
to do the video did you were to give you
a grade yes sir all right perfect
I blacked out too much head of state
stuff job seventh pick of the draft
Chicago Bulls and they are going with a
Dukey Wendell Carter jr. who you told me
earlier safest pick in the draft yeah
there's not many questions to ask except
how high does the ceiling go but man
look at his body MBA MBA physical
profile 610 to 57 four and a half
wingspan not the most explosive athlete
but not a stiff either they're like a
range e for like what do you see from
him I see how Horford and that's a very
popular comparison Derrick Favors Al
Horford that type of player more of an
old-school player but he he can extend
his range a little bit he knocked down
around 40% of his three is this season
his bread-and-butter though is that low
post he's got really good footwork I
could turn over either shoulder one of
the top rebound there's offensive
rebounders in this Jeff he's gonna get
you a lot of second-chance points and
you blocked three point one shots per 40
minutes so it gives you some rim
protection on the weak side question is
can you switch out and defend for us
because that would really improve his
value if he could play that floor
position but he won't have to in Chicago
that's marketing when Doc Carter will
play that five and replace Robin Lopez
long term
all right so seventh pick of the draft
obviously Wendell Carter what is your
grade to get him at that spot and and
you know will he be an impact player in
year one I think he's gonna play right
away I give me the B+ because there's
somebody else I liked a little bit
better but what was it I liked me Cal
bridges from Villanova filling that
whole wing I think it's tougher to find
a wing in today's
is to find a back to the basket score
but never mind that Carter's a fine pick
you can't go wrong with him he does the
things that marketing doesn't marketing
is more of a finesse guy who's gonna
play around the perimeter
whereas Carter is more of a powerful
physical presence around the basket hey
powerful and physical I like it bowls
you got yourself a good guy on the low
post Wendell Carter is now dog bowls
we'll see how he does in year one okay
so whoa just saying Collin Sexton
apparently to the Cavs right now what
are you thinking about Wendell Carter
Howard what are you thinking about sex
didn't what do you thing about
everything you're here well the Bulls is
interesting again a team that's very
young right now having blown it up
sending out Jimmy Butler a year ago at
this time last last draft that was when
they made that big franchise altering
trade and the early returns were
actually pretty good Chris done before
he got hurt was really emerging as a
really nice point guard I'd be curious
to hear Terry's uh two reviews of Chris
Dunn and Levine came back from the ACL
was looking pretty good mark and ahead
of strong rookie season like you can see
this thing coming together that the
Bulls might not be down for that long if
guys grow up quickly
you know it's throw Wendell Carter into
the mix and see how that goes I mean
let's see you know they're gonna hold on
to Lopez for a while they're gonna hold
on to some of these other vets to kind
of balance it out and bring these guys
along but you know I like where the
Bulls are going right now I mean they've
taken a lot of hits and some of them
deserved but I feel like they're in a
good spot what do you think Terry you
like the Bulls where they're going I
like where it's done I like Bobby Portis
I like Tony hope they not play around
yet I don't they around like it's on you
no biggie so hopefully them guys is
trying to make some noise in the East
but you know like I'm with the Celtics
so a lot of these guys but I do like I
am a fan of Chris Dunn I respect him a
lot and you know he's one of the guys
that you know you know what you gonna
get out of him he's gonna play hard and
things like that so it's interesting to
see how a roster uh-oh I'm gonna give
credit to anybody everybody's talking
right now about how the Celtics are like
gonna be the team in the East and I'm
excited the team that you battled the
Cavaliers we heard that Collins sex it
might be the guy
and we've worked with Collin Sexton
before and apparently he can hit shots
that aren't traditional so here's Collin
Sexton doing that be our thing
[Music]
Terry could you do that yeah I could do
that
Terry trick shot videos and one mixtape
tour coming we'll just put you on the
top of buildings and just throw balls
off was that his first take yes yes it
was kind of Sexton it the first day if
you make deadness you notice like you
and me went out there and we just
started throw them all one of us gonna
hit it there's no chance you make it
before me though I will bet you however
much that shirt colors yeah I wouldn't
bet that I'm gonna do that too much
yeah yeah this is Banana Republic or
something alright so Collin Sexton to
the Cavs you guys let me know we're
ready to give your grade for that yep
what did you give me or a b-plus so this
is a guy that I remember hearing about
Collin six in Alabama he goes out there
and right they need to play like three
on five or four on five or something
like that three on five against
Minnesota and he dropped 40 and almost
brought the team back I was nuts you
remember seeing that right that was when
I got introduced to Collin Sexton so
what is it like when you as a player you
see three on five and this dude's drop
in for tea I mean that's crazy you don't
really see that especially you know in
college you got to finish the game three
on five and you still score forty they
came up short
yeah same but should have been though
yes hat goes off Sam he's you know he
did what he had to do with yeah that's
tough and a lot of guys can do that
alright so let's see how Johnny wass
thinks he fits in with the Cavaliers and
honestly I don't know if they're gonna
have LeBron so let's find out let's do
the video
Collin Sexton gets buckets so with the
eighth pick of the drift the Cavaliers
take that man out of Alabama and I'm
curious you had him as your 17th ranked
player how much of a reach was this I
thought it was actually a perfect fit oh
he wasn't the best player on my board
but I love what Sexton brings to the
table in Cleveland he kind of reminds me
of Terry Rozier I mean this is the same
old you know I kind of messed up the
evaluation with Terry coming out of
college I'm not gonna make the same
mistake twice and overlook the assistant
turnover ratio and the shooting
percentage Sexton is one of the most
competitive players like Terry in this
draft and I think that's what Cleveland
needs particularly for that point guard
position somebody who could put pressure
on defense and pressure opposing ball
handlers make life difficult for them so
this gives them another weapon in the
lineup I don't know if LeBron James is
gonna be back right regardless this is
just a guy you want in your locker room
a guy you want on the floor his
competitiveness is contagious hmm all
right so what the great cuz you just got
me hyped as a hell for Collin Sexton I
give it a b-plus and honestly if
somebody else took him I probably
wouldn't have given that good a grade
but I just love to fit this is something
that they need they need a just a punch
of this energy of his demeanor and again
if he can improve his jump shot and
LeBron James comes back and sex it
doesn't have to worry so much about
getting other guys involved sex ins you
know his bread and butter is scoring
this guy averaged like 30 a game in AAU
he can catch fire and take over and once
he's in the zone he's a microwave so I
really like the fit I think he feels in
need there and and they're gonna really
like it in Cleveland I saw that six
eight reach for a guy in size is pretty
unbelievable
Collin Sexton whether LeBrons there or
not was-- loves the picks for the Cavs
oh oh we have a strange tweet before I
get Terry's reaction to that player
being compared to Terry master in June
take us to the Twitterverse left Co I've
got something very spicy for you right
now the ringers Roger Sherman tweeted
Donovan Mitchell's doing interviews for
the arena Jumbotron and just told Jared
Jackson jr. he was quote the newest
member of the Utah Jazz as it was
already announced here in Jackson junior
was selected seventh by the Chicago
Bulls fourth I was a fourth Memphis
cares
yeah okay as you can see the Hennessy
and then we have we have another draft
pick
according to shams Tirana of Yahoo at
the number one not at the number nine
overall pick the New York Knicks are
selecting Kevin Knox of Kentucky oh yeah
our office going crazy about some right
now no probably that was Kevin oh we got
big faces oh that's right so what are
you cheering I'm a big logo fan but
Kevin Knox I've seen his grind this
summer he's whipped my agency so you
know I'm just happy to see how I told
guys he was gonna go big that yes now
when you come to New York you got a guy
you could stay with agent can hook it up
you guys go to 1 oak you hit me up and
you bring Howard back when I come to New
York I got a guy can score on as that's
big-time
that's big-time Kevin Knox was I feel
like the darling of the workouts did you
hear that as well I feel like everywhere
he went people were enthralled by him
yeah I mean yeah to the extent that you
can actually trust anything that you
hear about people being enthralled by
workouts everybody looks great in a
workout you know jingling right yeah
there you go yeah yeah nice pick there
by Kiki Vandeweghe
yes no you know the the Knicks are to me
in talent acquisition mode this is a
team that is I they never won admit it
they're still kind of rebuilding
they made it kind of a futile and I
think foolish you know attempt to run
for the eighth seed last year fell far
short obviously a lot of that was about
porzingis going down but they weren't
gonna make it anyway I like that they've
got another just kind of energetic young
player to put in there next to Neal
Akina and porzingis when he's healthy
they just need to keep building
organically yeah at this point
stop trying for the quick fixes there
was talk earlier in the evening of
course of them trying to make that move
up two to four I'm not sure who that
would have been necessarily if they had
done the Chandler Parsons swap probably
better off that they're not doing that
they've gotten themselves in enough tap
health situations over the years and
this kid is still freaking 18 you're to
give them your grade I did oh that's why
you're doing like
your breath I was like I'm having memory
loss disease b-plus all right I love
this because it looks like my Sixers
mikkel bridges is falling into their lap
and I really hope that that happens
don't tell me if it's happening one
experience at live let's do Kevin Knox
going to the Knicks
Edna McCain every year a Kentucky player
goes in the top ten and this is again
one of those years Kevin Knox going
number nine to the Knicks kid is still
18 and you had him going right at around
number 11 what do you think of the value
here good value I think the most
impressive thing that the next here did
was take a really young guy and not
worry about winning next year because
Knox may need time he's just so young
but he led Kentucky and scoring like you
said 18 years old and he did it without
being a bald dominant player this guy
plays strictly off the ball obviously
you see in transition he's a really
smooth athlete six nine sighs I think he
could play both of those forward spots
to thirteen long arms so a combo forward
I think those are valued in today's NBA
but this is a guy like I said plays off
the ball made 1.5 threes per game he's
more of a catch take one dribble and
slash throw up a floater pull-up he's
not going to you know dance with the
ball for too long install your offense
I think he's gonna play really nicely
between porzingis when he comes back and
Tim Hardaway jr. warm up for a ball
Stoppers guys you give the ball to and
kind of stand around a little bit
occasionally he's gonna be a perfect fit
in between them offensively great for
this book this is a b-plus right in that
mix for best player on the board and
again three NBA seasons under his belt
he's still gonna be 21 years old he's
gonna get better and he was still very
productive at Kentucky has the chance to
improve defensively he struggled a
little bit there didn't rebound
particularly well but letting but on
some muscle
let him mature a little bit I think he's
gonna be just fine in those departments
and offensively his up side is as good
as any forwards in this draft the big
question was were they gonna take
Michael Porter Jr who was still on the
board right now guy was projected number
one overall before the season so
obviously something wrong with his back
Kevin Knox a very safe pick let him
develop he's gonna fit nicely again
between Hardaway and porzingis Kevin
Knox was tweeting out earlier this
afternoon that
they got a new coach in New York well
apparently he knew that he was going
Kevin Knox now a Knick pick at number
nine what's up E - yeah yeah like
tweeted out earlier today he was on a
radio show like oh we got a new coach yo
he was going to New York next
all right so apparently master and Jun
have something that I want to go to
tarry semester and Jul what do you got
for us I mean we bout to send it back to
Terry real quick because the Knicks fans
ain't really feeling Kevin Knox boy they
over here booing them and they blew it
up
boo them as you can see our own PR
people were going nuts the social team
was going nuts because he had a bunch of
Knicks fans but as you can see from this
picture this kid in that trash next
cityedition uniform not look happy and
it's dad it looks like it was what do
you think they're booing your guy is
never happy either
- christian porzingis three stops they
boo him so they don't really matter you
add at the same time you still got to
perform when you step on that court
fans can boo whoever they want they can
have the opinions yeah I could go back
to when I got drives I asked so much
negative feedback I had guys calling I
had to get on get on the phone with
media after I got drafted and they asked
me questions you know just tricky
questions like how you know just just
like negative negative things so it's
not enlarge yeah it's a whatever but at
the same time you still got to get into
between them lines and you still got to
play and show what you're capable of so
I'm happy for them it you know I know
the Knicks fit the next fans a big-time
out here so yeah so we saw that picture
angry fans what is it like everyone
comes up to you before the draft and
goes your life is going to be so
different and it's all positive and then
you get drafted and then there's
negative energy was it surprising what
does that experience like as a human is
a feeling you can't describe I just go
back to the drive - stayed at home had a
draft party didn't eat the whole day you
know nervous yeah but bought so many
hats not knowing where he was gonna go
get drafted 16 you heard a negative
report and stuff like that but you don't
really fall into it because you're so
happy of what you accomplished with your
family you share that you share their
moment with your family and friends you
don't really care about that but like I
said I think Kevin ox is when you get in
between them lines and
when this opportunity to come he's gonna
he's gonna take care of business he's
gonna run with it have a lot of fun with
it awesome thank you for sharing that
sure I really hope them the Cal bridges
is going to the Sixers this would be a
great Sixers moment if anyone the next
week
that's why sixes are up man oh yeah here
let's go to master Jude tell me that
words don't let go let go I think you're
gonna be really really happy according
to laws at number ten overall the Sixers
are targeting Villanova's and mikkel
bridges Oh targeting you know a lot of
people are talking about the Celtics
just running away with the East who
we're gonna run away I got one of them
next to me Oh guess what
Ben Simmons is gonna get a mid-range
game chu LMB just a healthy tease me
drop bombs all over the place and
they're gonna kick out and who's that oh
it's not you it's not me it's Miguel
Miguel bridges the bridge to the Eastern
Conference Finals Kyrie Irving
Corey Hayward Daniel theis don't forget
those three so those three versus your
god I just got dressed who you taking I
didn't I know you guys are don't be a
lot of fun though these makes a lot of
smack talking a lot of Twitter fingers
from Jolin B's your guy got no fight
with Joel is there can you try to draw
snitch to the media I try to swing on
him twice and said I was too sure at all
yeah so I grew up with my dad telling me
that the Sixers Celtics robber was like
the best thing ever
can you feel one blossoming right now
like can you confirm that there's like a
legit rivalry starting to bloom you
could feel it you could fill it with
showed your affiliate is when when they
lost and B didn't even want to shake
hands he left off and I'm not you know
not throwing shade no and anything at
that but you you could tell that just
lets you know right there how how much
like they want to beat us how much we
want to beat them and it's gonna be for
the next couple years like how
don't happen he's gonna be like he like
yeah like yeah all right special at the
same point imma bust your ass with ever
sixes you don't have to do the fred
parts let's shake on the front part okay
Fred part okay the rest of it I dare you
okay good alright so I'm pretty excited
wasps is gonna make me more excited well
I don't know what the greatest do not
tell me the grade until then Terry
Rozier I'm gonna bet you a large stack
that the Sixers beat you next year I'm
not because I don't have that much I
don't all throughout the mock draft
process there was one guy being linked
to the Sixers constantly Mikkel bridges
played in Philadelphia at Villanova he
was that perfect three and D kind of guy
how excited she I be as a six-percent
very excited he was the best player on
my board I think they got as good a
value as they could have gotten the only
knock on the account bridges today it
turns 22 years old in August I just
bought a number John I don't think it's
a big deal I think he fits perfectly
with the roster and the cliche is he's a
3 and D guy 43% from downtown one of the
best defenders in the draft guards
positions 1 through 4 shoots around 60%
inside the arc only takes good shots he
can't hurt you even on those really bad
days which he doesn't have many of I
think he fits perfectly around the star
players in Philly alright so I'm excited
I want to hear this great what are you
giving bridges at 10 to the 6 years I
mean they get neck
aren't too hard to find the problem with
this pic like I said before I think he's
gonna fit perfectly with the star guys
around him feeling they need a guy who
can come in and help you without taking
away dribbles from embiid or Simmons and
I think folks is gonna need some
dribbles next year bridges a guy who's
gonna give you 15 points and defend and
never use a dribble the whole game he's
just too good of a fit low maintenance
guy everyone raves about him in the
locker room yes they needed a number of
guys that position it kind of showed a
weakness in the playoffs Belinelli
couldn't do some defense Redick out
there you get a guy that can do a little
bit of everything spread the floor on
becoming a draft analyst now 6 is very
excited McHale bridges number 10 Oh
it's always good to get the guy you want
right Howard back sure if you say so
oh thanks such enthusiasm all right I
heard a sound it was an air horn it does
not mean that pitbulls coming out he
doesn't mean that he's not coming out
later but it means that we have a trade
so let's go to our dynamic duo in the
corner of the room master in June we
have a potential trade but first Jun
will announce the news of who the
Charlotte horns will pickled 11 the
Hornets are going to take a number 11
overall che gilja's Alexander woo
but whoa just tweeting that Charlotte is
in trip discussion to trade
possibilities for the 11th overall pick
Phoenix has wanted to get back into the
lottery to get one of the elite point
guards and Alexander is the focus that
the Suns have so interest Hornet so far
I've drafted him could go to Phoenix we
don't know yet there's also one more
report from mark Stein he says leaked
sources say the Clippers have been
trying to lure the Spurs into Kawhi
Leonard trade talks with an offer
featuring their two lotto picks and
Tobias Harris but it appears they'll be
making the 12th and 13th pick for
themselves with Michael Porter jr. still
on the board Dan
China I got to buy his Harris bro yeah
Tobias Harris is the man all right Helen
so SGA che gilja's Alexander if he in is
indeed traded to the Suns they would
come out of there with him and DeAndre
Aiden which is pretty dynamic I would
say I kind of want to touch on that
Kauai news is everybody call the Spurs
right now is everybody just kind of
doing a heat check to see if it's
possible you have to I mean you you're
obligated to if you're not making that
call you're you're it's a dereliction of
duty at this point there's no indication
yet that the Spurs are ready to give up
on Kawhi Leonard there's no indication
that they have decided that that they
have to move on
you know we've not heard from anybody
nor can we really the Spurs are never
gonna talk publicly anyway they're the
Patriots of the NBA and Kawhi Leonard
and his camp literally cannot say
publicly they want to trade it's against
NBA rules you can be fined it hasn't
happened in a long time but it's not
something you can say oh teri allowed to
talk about Kawhi Leonard you could talk
about Kawhi Leonard a person right like
is the
da are you guys like wondering what's
gonna happen with Kauai right now cuz
that's all we're talking about now
everybody's wondering what's gonna go on
what's gonna happen I think tonight
period with with everything like we feel
like tonight still gonna be crazy if you
got a call and it was like Terry you
have a new teammate and his name's Kawhi
Leonard would you be excited yeah let's
go Outlander
there's a guy what happens what happens
if I got that list in the league what if
I got a call but what if I got alert
right and it's something you go get it
before you but Kauai gets traded to the
Celtics and you get set to say Antonio
would you be pissed
or did you be like I get to play with
Popovich how would you handle that I
mean Boston is Boston I love Boston I
feel like is there's no other
organization like that and me I was down
by it's probably because I've been there
yeah on three years but you know I don't
know how I feel let's just hope that
don't happen
okay I kind of want it just cuz I want
to be here with you and then like would
just like cut off the shell well let go
I believe it is yeah alright so a
Clippers were trying to make the trade
che Gill Geus gilja's Alexander all
right so are we doing this as though
he's going to the Hornets are we doing
as always going to the suns guys so he's
going to the Hornets oh so it's Sun so I
left did you master in June you got some
clarification here yes we do John gam Bo
out in Phoenix Phoenix radio host
he said the suns will trade with the
Clippers that was as of three minutes
ago we haven't seen any trade details
yet or anybody else confirming that he
will be traded to the south but it seems
like Alexander can be a son
all right so but actually from what
you're saying if they're trying to trade
with the Clippers that means Alexander
will be going to the Hornets excuse me
yeah yeah I was going to the Hornets
here right now the Clippers have
acquired Gil just Alexander trade with
the Hornets so that's okay oh wait time
out you're telling me that Alexander is
now going to the Clippers the Clippers
have acquired Alexander to the Hornets
gamble said the Suns are gonna trade
with the Clippers Clippers obviously I'm
back-to-back picks and it seems like the
quick clip
have acquired Alexander and a trade with
the Hornets it's getting man he's gonna
be sent then to the sons we are we will
figure this out I like him alive
all right gone while you guys figure
this out Terry what do you know about
this kid
yeah ballplayer so you've seen him a few
times yeah see what do you like about
him his size him just him be employs him
just I feel like he he thinks the game
he's just he's just he's exciting to
watch so I'm excited to see where he end
up and just see how you know how you
start off is his best worker here
awesome I've decided we're gonna do him
going to the Hornets right all right
don't ask me all right let's go back to
master who is dropping master bombs all
over here master what do we got we got
you guys now thank you
ouch says the Clippers will send the
12th pick in two second-round picks to
the Hornets for Alexander okay so
Alexander is a clipper all right does
that change your grade at all are you
good I'm good okay let's do this we're
ready to the video pronounce his name
for me
Shay Gil just Alexander Shay gilja's
Alexander SGA yes same great man that's
the thing about the NBA Draft that's so
crazy is that we don't know which trades
are really going through until later on
sports crazy bro but he's go to the
Clippers we have we have another report
though from okay thanks guys
Los Angeles Clippers are going with a
man with three big names che gilja's
Alexander the point guard from Kentucky
not a lot of great point guards in this
class but I know you liked this guy what
do you think about him going to clips
and they trade it up to get him yeah
whether he went to the Clippers are the
sons of the Hornets he somebody's
getting a good player here and it sounds
like LA is getting their new starting
point guard he looks long 611 wingspan 6
I mean these their measurements for a
wing and he is a lead ball handler very
smooth not very explosive but he doesn't
need it he kind of compensates but this
off the dribble game has changed a
direction his change of speed
intelligent player a table Center he's
more of a facilitator than they use a
scorer but he's very crafty inside the
arc
it didn't shoot a lot from outside he
shot a good percentage he takes those
good shots that find him in the offense
alright so getting him it around here
the pick is at 11 you had him going
around 12 so it makes sense the grade
for the Clippers this is a b-plus he was
around the best player available and
they need a point guard and they got a
big one to play alongside Lou Williams
who's more of an undersized to guard
Gilda's out there also a very good
defender and I think they needed some
defense in that backcourt this is a guy
who's gonna run their offense
efficiently press the right buttons make
some good decisions be an efficient
player I'm so really tough to find
anything wrong with this picture alley
la see locking it down with SGA we'll
see what the kentucky kid can do in his
first year with the clubs all right so
they traded they didn't trade the 13th
pick also did they the Clippers did so
the trade is the Clippers will get
Alexander and they're trading the 13th
pick so they're picking for the Hornets
and with the 13th overall pick they're
selecting Myles bridges all right so
wait was that the 12th pick so the
Clippers will select Myles bridges with
the number 13 overall pick gosh writing
him to Charlotte for Alexander so who is
going 12 because the Clippers had 12 out
of 13 right you'll just go just
Alexander went he went good you want 11
11 11 Shum says that the Clippers are
taking Jerome Robbins
with the 13th pick oh all right so we're
having a lot of reports here a lot of
different teams this is what happens
when one team has 12 and 13 and they
trade one we sit there and we go I don't
know what's going on if it is indeed
Jerome Robinson at 13 that's exactly
what you had tell me about this kid
because you said the number one question
you get when you do radio interviews is
who's the Donovan Mitchell of this draft
and you said I mean who the heck knows
my binocs walls Terry says Kevin Knox
but you said the one guy that could be
is Jerome Robinson he's the best
candidate he was kind of slept on for
most of the year average 24 a game in
the ACC and nobody knew because Boston
College was pretty lousy but this is a
six five two guard who can create his
own shot from all three levels step
backs pull-ups three-point range can
attack the basket and also get some guys
involved again if this team was any
better you'd know more about him but
number thirteen I think that's a fine
pick I think he's gonna surprise a lot
of people awesome
all right so we're getting to the point
of the draft where Terry went and I'm
curious so we're at like 12 13 were you
getting calls at this point did you know
you were gonna be going soon or is it
just complete doubt like you just sit
back in just and just wait you know you
around your family how much my thing was
different than a lot of other guys I was
at in the house with my family and
friends and you know you just not know
when your name gonna get caught and I
remember lights being in my face right
before his 16th pick so I kind of
figured like as my name really by the
gate call right now because there's like
the news was there from Cleveland and
yeah they start shining in my face right
before the bosses so it's elected they
pick so it's just like but it's still
like before that you just don't know
nobody called me he told my agent my
agent I want to tell me he just wanted
me to just find out from the TV we had
the TV on and everybody was there he
made sure everybody gather around I was
set up perfectly oh but the new was kind
of gave it away when eight when they had
the lights shining in my face but it
still like surreal like you still can't
believe it like they really want to save
money what was it like when your name
pops up on the
bottom of the screen your name is it's a
feeling that you can't get back it's an
unbelievable feeling this is crazy man I
jumped in the pool with my drafts in all
I think a lot of people know about that
really yeah that video I got video of
that I tripped in a fool each report
we're gonna put it up yeah we'll put
that up online real quick all right so
we're gonna do miles bridges
so actually miles bridges is the one
that's going back to the Hornets okay so
Mott so I'm just going off the B R AB
here the 11th pick was SGA he is going
to the Clippers the 12th pick miles
bridges he is now going to the Hornets
that's a trait and in addition the
Hornets will also be getting two
second-round picks depending on how you
value second-round picks it's a good
trade or not so does that change your
miles bridges pick now that he's going
to the Hornets ah you know it does a
little bit okay no way so what were you
gonna give it if you went to the
Clippers a b-minus and then how does it
change now if it goes to the hold I
think it's he's exactly what the Hornets
need so I'm okay with it he wasn't the
best player available on my board right
so what grade would you give it now I'm
gonna go with it B now okay all right so
we're gonna do the video and you're
gonna explain why it's the perfect fit
for the Hornets and why it wasn't gonna
be the guys for the Clippers Myles
bridges another Michigan State guy two
of them go in the top 12 this one he's a
big body so let's see how he can do in
the Hornets ready to do this
after a trade miles bridges will be the
first round pick for these Charlotte
Hornets and I know that you just said
this before we did this video the
perfect fit why they need scoring from
those forward spots Marvin Williams
kidd-gilchrist there's no firepower
there bridges is a shot-maker
he gives them a big upgrade at the three
or four he played three most of his
career at Michigan State I actually
think he's more of a four at the NBA
level we can exploit his quickness his
explosiveness he's one of the top
athletes in the draft as you see him fly
above the rim here but also made two
threes per game and back-to-back seasons
improved a little bit this year with his
Shah creativity but it's going to be
easier for him with more space playing
the four against slower footed guys and
I think he should be able to start right
away Charlotte oh that's awesome
what is your grade for this pick and who
does he remind you of I give it a B he
reminds me of man Larry Johnson type
really from back in the day I'm a BA and
an undersized tower phone he measured
under six seven and sneakers but he kind
of compensates with this ride frame is
his explosiveness and you can knock down
that 3-ball now the question is does he
developing in between game can he take
you off the dribble can you score in the
post so we'll see what happens there but
I think his floor is kind of held up by
his athleticism and shooting all right
an immediate impact player miles bridges
the pick for the Charlotte Hornets we'll
see him on the floor almost immediately
when it's fans get excited
all right so now that means that it's
back to the Clippers again right and
that's where we're gonna go Jerome
Robinson at 13 perfect
alright so Jerome Robinson this was your
guy I have never seen this guy play
basketball ever and I don't think Terry
has either so I'm excited to watch these
highlights you watch these bad boys you
tell me what you think
Howard what is your take on the last few
picks I haven't heard from you a little
bit and I like to hear your voice well
let's start with the Clippers you know
this is a team that again a team is in
transition
Chris Paul forces the trade out a year
ago next week
Blake Griffin gets dealt shockingly at
midseason and so they're kind of
starting over and the point guards that
they had last year of course they
couldn't keep healthy Tiye dosage
everybody was really excited about Pat
Beverly who was a great pick up in there
Chris Hall trait neither of them you
know of Everly basically missed the
season potatoes it's missed a lot of it
so that you're plugging in an exciting
young point guard with size on this team
that's a start you know maybe he's
pairing up you know maybe he's the next
guy throwing all those great lobs to
DeAndre Jordan I'm still curious to see
if they hang on to DeAndre Jordan or
this is a real rebuild or they trying to
go that middle road where you don't
really kind of tear down too far you
don't get all the way to young
yeah I'll be curious to see what else
comes behind this and clearly we've
already seen the reports from mark Stein
about them trying to get in on the Kauai
sweepstakes and what combination of guys
do they have that might be able to make
that happen
the Clippers going to be aggressive you
know Lawrence Frank is hanging up that
basketball operations department of
course but Jerry West brought in as the
consultant you know quietly they're in
the backroom Oh Jerry West is not one
who is going to ever allow anyone around
him to kind of stand pat they're gonna
be aggressive alright so now we're gonna
do the video Jerome Robinson is now
going to the Clippers Ross said that if
there's one guy that could be a Donovan
Mitchell it might be this guy let's
watch the highlights let's hear the
great I don't know what it's gonna be
Jerome Robinson a BC open Terry Rozier
is neck of the woods heading out to l.a
I want to move to LA me and Terry are
good apartment together we're gonna go
the beach there's no surf lessons we'll
see what's good trigger martini
second of two first-round picks for the
LA Clippers so they're going Jerome
Robinson of Boston College haven't seen
a Boston College guy go this high at a
while you think this kid's got potential
y24 a game in the ACC I mean that is not
easy he is a flame thrower I mean he can
catch fire and take over six six guards
six I'd say creates his own shot from
every level on the floor three-point
range pull-ups step backs can get to the
basket with change of speed a good
handle and his ability to lose guys off
the dribble naturally translates to
assist opportunities I think he's gonna
be a very productive player you see he
can kind of explode off the floor a
little bit so he is an offensive weapon
that LA just got in terms of the makeup
of the team in the grade what are you
giving it and how do you think he fits I
give it a B+ I think it was a very
sneaky pick because he didn't generate a
lot of attention during the year this is
a guy who flew up draft boards if you
speak to him listen to him he's very
articulate very well grounded
down-to-earth type of guy but clearly
somebody who may have been undervalued
underappreciated during the year and
teams finally got to see man this guy
could play go back and review the film
he torched every ACC podium in Virginia
even Virginia this guy just wow catches
fire and once he's on fire he's one of
those guys where defense good defense
doesn't even matter and he's just he's
gonna put the ball in the basket when
he's on whether you're defending him
tell you not wow so the Clippers pretty
much go out on this draft and they build
their backcourt of the future SGA and
now Jerome Robinson yeah that's where
they're going that's the new faces of LA
Jerry West getting it done for the clips
we'll see what he can do in year one
what did you think you watch the
highlights is he going to be a stud off
30 seconds of YouTube I mean it's tough
to call it but it looks like an NBA is
gonna be a lot more space for him to
open up and go to work good luck he he
can he can enter the ball how much of a
great is inside like how much of a
different game is that from college
really open it like I always hear that
oh the NBA it opens up what does it feel
like as a player it just is just more is
more especially I think about in college
you got guys who sitting in the lane
it's not a three second so you obviously
you're getting scouted so you got guys
who sit in the lane that's long
like that so obviously it make it tough
you in the lead the lane is kind of
opened up because you you you you you
plan with shooters you plan with guys
that's on a pro level who who work at
they game every day so you got past that
first guy and you get that first guys
kind of opened up and if it is not then
you plant with ballplayers you can
really dump it off to you all right the
riverboat missile a on the NBA so if
it's three feet spread out that means
guys are further away from the lane
right Plus NBA guys they like to push
the pace college is more methodical slow
it down right well you're playing like
Virginia and stuff I was curious man I
saw you do this a few times this year
you did against the Sixers Joel embiid
how long did you work on the like
releasing a layup from like all the way
out here like did you did you recently
like attain that I feel like every time
you went up you released it like all the
way out here yeah I mean that's just
something that you you you work on going
against like bigger guys so that's how
that you start working on during the
summer because you know guys it's coming
to go get your stuff even the guys like
Mahmoud is just gonna draft yeah he's
going trying to block everybody SWAT
yeah so you know you just gotta find a
way to just see guys like Kyrie Irving
and Curry's who who does a great job at
finishing and you know as just kind of
the finesse game you just got to work on
different angles of the backboard yeah
Howard Beck's type of game yeah well I
got Denver on the clock I don't know
what we got if you know what's going on
or if Howard you want to chime in you
got anything right now but Denver
Nuggets what do you got for us fellas so
according to woge Denver has been
seriously considering Porter Jr with
number 14 overall bull you're deciding
now kind of reminds me of the Harry
Giles situation last year where you know
my trials fell down to number 22 the
Kings played 23 games 26 games with Duke
Porter obviously played three last year
with Missouri it's kind of hard to low
just wording to figure out if this is
like him tipping another pick or he's
actually just yes so what were what
wordings do we have four modes as far uh
targeting targeting prefers focused on
zeroing in prefers deciding on yeah do
we think that
Rhodes went on thesaurus.com and tried
to find 30 words instead of will be
taking the speck you know watch well I
mean look I just think that this is one
of the interesting revelations of the
night and Terry you should appreciate
this reporters are really competitive
too and you can't just turn off
competitive instincts right so when an
edict comes down that says don't tip the
picks ahead of time wait for them to be
announced on TV and you're telling
reporters who have already are
conditioned to say well my competition
is going to tweet out these picks if I
don't you find a way oh I can't use that
word I'll use another word like oh I
can't get to the basket well watch me
pull up for this three right yeah oh
you're gonna guard the three-point line
watch me pull up from 30 feet instead
like you adjust what was suggesting he's
got he's got more in his arsenal so I
don't know do you do like do you have
Twitter
guys what do you follow watch I don't
okay yeah I see a lot of guys retweet
back though okay make sure I do that you
know the information now Michael Porter
I feel like is the the wild card in this
draft
we talked beforehand there were two guys
that might fall and it was either going
to be Trey young or Michael Porter
it was Porter is this where is this as
far as you thought he would go or is
just further than you thought this is
further and there must have been some
bad news in those medical reports
obviously a back injury is not ideal
for a player this young and though back
injury people who know who had them they
linger and yet back spasms the other day
had to shut down the pro day to him so I
guess people are getting nervous this
also happens to be a very strong draft
so you know you're there's a lot of good
players to take and you don't want to
take the risk
yeah guy with a back injury so all right
so was still tweeting and Adrian
Komarovsky is just feasting on all of
his little music source Denver has clear
the way to choose Michael Porter Jr with
the 14th pick actually he said the 14 H
pick so we don't know if that's the 14th
a rare woods typo or another type yo the
14-hour pick who knows burn off the
weight of I think it's his waves it's
not tipping if you misspelled a word
that's true baby what you were saying
though about Michael Porter Jr all the
guys that have gone before him I haven't
heard you say a ton of questions like
column sexing
he's got to work on his shot but this is
the real first guy where I'm hearing a
lot of questions Trey young people are
kind of hot or cold with him but the
back if he was six five
would we be as concerned because it's
six eleven bat big guys with backs is
like always the scary thing ya know his
posture even before the injury guy said
he had a high waist he didn't have a
great posture he was never somebody who
exploded off the floor now he was
coordinated I think people mistake
athleticism and explosiveness and
coordination they're all kind of
different explosiveness was never part
of his game and the back injury for a
guy that skinny who plays around the
perimeter and would have to guard power
forwards at the next level that is
certainly concerned it's always
interesting the number one recruit
coming out of high school I feel like
that follows you throughout the draft
process and usually can kind of get you
higher than this but he's going 14 you
guys ready to do Michael Porter to
Denver let's do it let's do it alright
oh what's your grade gonna be nobody
listen man let's go at this point let's
go with him be be
now you don't be plus people P+ have you
seen this kid play no cuz he's played
like eight minutes cuz he was injured
the whole time alright so Michael Porter
junior former number one player coming
out of high school kids like 611 he's
only 20 years old I feel like he's
turning
he turned like 20 today so let's see
what Woods thinks about watch wasps
thinks about him going to Denver with
the 14th pick
he's our watch everybody was wondering
where is Michael Porter junior going to
go he's going to Denver
the Nuggets at pick number 14 good value
at this point why not you know there was
only one guy I would have taken a head
of Porter at this point if I was Denver
in that zyre Smith from Texas Tech but
like you said this was the number one
player in his high school class
he's 611 he is a scorer and with that
size and his scoring ability he is gonna
be a very difficult mismatch if he can
stay on the floor now you know it's
anybody's guess what though were in
those medical reports and how much his
back and durability holds up but if
does then forget to steal at number 14
right
hey to me it feels like a potential play
if you hit right now at the end of
lottery it's all worth it if not you
kind of have an excuse as to why it
didn't work
what's your grade for this and how do
you think this all plays out for michael
poulsen well give it a b-plus because
this is just a good buy low pick at
number 14 you can't expect to land a
star and he actually does have star
potential and normally you don't get
that type of potential this late in the
first round Denver has a lot of forwards
they needed actually they don't really
don't need any specific thing they have
kind of depth at every position maybe
point guard they could have used next to
Jamal Murray but he'll play the three
he'll play the four I actually think it
kind of makes sense in Denver he doesn't
have to do too much early on he can kind
of come off the bench take it slow he
only played 53 minutes this season so
whole season the whole season so he's
not ready for a full workload so
actually I guess it makes sense for him
to take it slow come off the bench play
it like a catch and shooter kind of the
way Jason Tatum did in Boston
alright so we're gonna see Michael
Porter Jr we're talking all potential
right now 53 minutes of college
basketball less than Kyrie Irving's like
seven games but we'll see Michael Porter
Jr the new guy for the Denver Nuggets 53
minutes oh look you hear that noise that
means we go to the boys according to
watch the wizards with the number 50
overall pick are gonna select Roy brown
out of Oregon Candice Buckner of The
Washington Post says that Troy Brown had
worked out with the Wizards on June 11th
I think this is the stunner I don't
think a lot of people expecting this
sure I and and with the number 16
overall pick according to Mark Steyn the
Suns are gonna select Dante d pinch n so
as Y the board for you left oh man T
Vincenzo he was the dude that dropped 30
in the championship game and then people
went through old tweets and they went
from a great night to an awful night
that's what Twitter can do it's not
worth it don't tweet just to lead them
all Mark Cuban expire it's great app you
should get it
but Troy Brown they announced that and
waswhen Wow so you're very surprised you
give your grade back what do you think
about everything tonight I just got to
learn from the BR at
the story of the night is woods avoiding
all of the I can't believe ESPN's
allowing this to happen but and anything
on Michael Porter Jr Troy Brown JD
Vincenzo the other thing in Washington I
talked about this earlier this evening
that Michael Porter jr. wasn't just the
back that had people concerned it was
also kind of attitude that his
interviews in Chicago at the pre-draft
combine people came away feeling like
the kids little strange kind of a big
sense of himself
maybe a little bit of entitlement there
and so there's concern about personality
and locker room fit and I even just got
a text or somebody's saying that's gonna
be a bad fit in that Denver locker room
because there's a lot of youth they're
still Jamal Murray's just getting
started yoga ch these are guys who are
just coming into their own you know a
more veteran Tevas where he would a fit
better I think it's gonna gonna connect
more a young yeah I think they don't
come together more but if a young guy
comes in these guys are semi established
now the young guy come in this next
rookie comes in and says well where's
where's mine this is a team with a lot
of offensive options you don't want the
rookie coming in saying I got a [ __ ]
like he's really come in and say where's
mine well he seems to have some tunnel
vision that's that's the sense I get if
his Wow don't you play how many games
well played 53 minutes the entire season
over three guys that he said he's
compared to Yanis McGrady KD K could
make a burden to KD KD
no no when you say they compared him to
KD he came out and he said he were he is
compared to KD Yanis and Tracy McGrady
said I'm so happy to be putting the same
sentence as those guys but he's the only
one that put himself in that sense so
you might probably try to market
yourself a little bit yeah but you know
at the same time you still gotta step
into reality even if you you got the
tunnel vision you've got to think you
bigger than what you are you still got a
step that you still got to play you
still got to come in and and earn your
stripes yes we see how that work maybe
maybe it's not easy coming in with the
with the younger guys thinking that you
can you know take over but where's the
where's the line for a young guy between
because you want confidence right you
the guy needs to feel like he belongs in
he's a show he belongs where's that that
line between confidence and you know too
much self confidence and cockiness of
you know I got to get mine where's I
think I think the coach plays a big part
in that how he treats him when he first
come in not not babying them letting
them know like you come in this is you
got to work for everything but at the
same time like we're professionals are
you coming this level you're a
professional so you got to take care of
business but it's gonna be interesting
to see because he is playing with
younger guys Jamal Murray
Jovovich things like that so we will see
is a tough one not everyone has your
coach that's the thing your coach is
amazing no yes no yes sir but what
you're trying to say I don't know guys
won't be successful if we didn't have
rest then my coach like mike maloney
Idol DeMarcus Cousins really well
Malone's a guy who's going to make sure
that guys you know know understand their
role and and play to it all right I'm
just trying to create drama like
teriyaki yeah I know I'm avoiding all
the drama my everything I'm trying to
get a reinigen teeth in there all right
so when this pick was made wass said wow
I don't know what grade he's making but
we're gonna find out Troy Brown a man
out of Oregon go to the Wizards at 15
let's see what wass picks let's do the
video
when wasps found out the Wizards were
taking Troy Brown he said one word Wow
15th pick you have this guy 24th on your
big board he's young but why did you say
wow I thought it was a little bit early
now I could see why they liked him but
I'm surprised they pulled the trigger at
number 15 I actually think they wanted
Jerome Robinson he was taken before but
okay let's talk about the positives he
does a lot yeah he kind of fits today's
mold as a guy who plays multiple
positions in position 'less basketball
he is a Wing he's almost that point when
he averages over three assists per game
this year so he can handle the ball and
get others involved any guards multiple
positions I think defense is gonna be
his calling card in the NBA particularly
early in his career guard fors threes
and guards but he needs to add a
specialty skill right now he doesn't
have any bankable skill that he can lean
on when he gets into leak alright so he
is only 18 years old
what Grady given him and do you think he
had just well in Washington does he fit
them I give it a b-minus and he's
probably not gonna play a ton right away
he's gonna come off the bench you know
out employer is gonna play in front of
him Kelly Oubre he's gonna play in front
of him Bradley Beal so is he gonna have
the minutes to develop and like you said
he's still 18 years old so they're not
gonna be able to get much from him for
the next year or two and the Wizards are
a team that's got to make a push I mean
they've had the same core for a long
time they got a long term project here
and you know like we said before we love
the idea of him but what does he do
right now that can help your team and
I'm not really sure not a great shooter
not a great shot creator good passer
does a little bit of everything a glue
guy type of player all right we'll see
if Troy Brown can realize that potential
a little bit sooner but he's going to
the Wizards and we'll see what he can do
in year one and beyond D Vincenzo okay
so Terry breaking news your best friend
in the NBA has just tweeted Joelle mb'd
has tweeted you're gonna read this how a
lot
either I play divas whoa what do you
think about Joelle Abid calling up the
first pick in the draft I mean he has he
has Twitter fingers oh you know that's
that's gonna happen he's gonna say how
you feel or whatever yeah he don't get
no don't make it entertaining yeah but
uh it's gonna be interesting I can't
wait to see the sun's play Phoenix now
it's uh Philadelphia 76ers but I do uh
you know I kind of I don't respect how
you try to drop snitch on me but I do
like how he talked his talk his stuff
it's kind of like not comparing them at
all to Muhammad I leave mom and I lead
you should going talking stuff in there
you still have to face them guys to do
talk stuff just Hawaiian I mean a song
white side up a tin down drum it so you
know it just make it interesting and it
is just the game needs that because a
lot of a lot of guys a lot of people
looking look into it and see what's
gonna happen with the matchups and stuff
so I think that's interesting yeah I
like with the NBA I thought that Mia is
this man I hate your guts but I'm not
gonna say it's like water down yeah yeah
he's out there doing it could you see
more guys to start talking crap out in
the open something ate this church it's
a lot of guys to talk talk stuff though
is you really you really gonna be a body
though who is the one guy that if he I'm
gonna curse should I curse yeah okay I
don't know my mom's watching I wouldn't
either
so who's one guy that if he actually
talked crap to you that you'd go he's so
about it that you wouldn't want to step
back to them at all like cuz there's no
Metta World Peace in the NBA right now
who would you if he can't if you like
hit you and you turned around you'd be
like oh my bad is there anything cuz I
know you're tough but he had no knowing
me I did nobody I can't I can't even see
me I came to picture me Santa God when
you go stag now fun it was to mark his
cousins you'd be like my bad bro
no look at you look at you my bad never
there's guys like em be the toggle of
smack both on the court and off so like
we the public know
exactly what he's saying because he does
it on social media all the time who are
the guys who are the best who we would
never know because it's not on social
media who the guys who were talking on
the court the best yeah jaelyn brah
really yeah oh that's Decatur jail Roz
actually funnier in court he's actually
funny all right give me some early like
if a guy stepping on the court like even
said summer these my first met Jaden
like if you don't know who he is he's
gonna really say it out loud like [ __ ]
you garden meat like say something like
that like that's awesome like who's is
that I look like it's always
entertaining me it's always always so
funny to me but that's the guy that you
probably wouldn't think talk stuff and
he talking stuff like JD ready came out
and tweeted that he has said something
Jalen had say yes all that so Jalen talk
is talking stuff that I think thank you
you say something but that's the best
insulting Superleague you just go I
don't know what the hell this guy
literally is so funny like who the hell
is this is he guarding me he says how he
says it's so low it's funny and then
you're kind of embarrassed for the guy
hey it's Carlos
all right I'm embarrassed master and
June made me feel less embarrassed yeah
Colin Sexson obviously was picked by the
Cavs earlier and he was he said as you
can see on the screen
LeBron let's do it let's go back to the
finals looks like Colin sexes trying
make this pitch to have LeBron come back
to Cleveland obviously a big decision
he's got to make your free agency put
that picture back up real quick I
thought you have some more exciting news
for us than that I was gonna say I was
gonna say LeBrons faces
oh now we've got some schools like that
look at LeBron the runs like Collin
Sexton
ain't staying for that man you got it
you got a pitch for LeBron to the
Celtics I asked you all embiid yesterday
and he told me just whistle blows all
right that's nice a pretty good
impersonation Philly so much you gonna
even make it you gonna make it away to
talk about Philly yeah I got to see my
Eagles win the Super Bowl man it was
nice that's big time you know I was I
was on a team with Marcus more so you
know just to see how happy he was it was
just oh man it was great so is there a
chance that the Morris twins actually
trade jerseys and like they stay super
so we don't realize like the Morris
twins like play for each other
ooh new pig in I just found out the
difference like this like what's the
difference one is just a little like a
little bit more brolic and that's the
one that that's not on my team all right
so are we doing Dante D Vincenzo or do
you want to get to the pic that's
apparently at 17
you guys got 17 the box for us we're
still in six no all right let's do 16
Dante D Vincenzo
you guys ready back there Villanova kid
Oh
sowhich comes back you guys want to
break this I want to hear Jun do it
so according to watch phoenixon seem to
be selecting at number 16 overall gyre
Smith
you mean zyre Smith yeah yeah higher
Smith Phoenix is determined to select
desire Smith all right so what's your
grade gonna be for this loss and Hey ooh
not a lot of guys coming out of Texas
Tech no sir no sir this is one of the
ones you'll remember this was the last
guy that went in your top ten you told
me before the draft that you saw a big
drop off after nine and that was Michael
Porter junior at number nine uh we got
ourselves an air [ __ ] and that means
it's masters time to drop the heat we've
got a sand bomb Sam is reporting
Philadelphia's trading mikkel bridges to
Phoenix for zyre Smith
I'm so sorry I talked all there they
will also ship
Miami's 2021 first round pick as well
okay would you so that Sixers player
that I was really excited about
they just traded them to the sun's for
the guy that he's gonna talk about Wow
plus a first round what's the first
round there in a couple years Miami's so
here's my question
your team has got yet another pic oh we
can we got a first-round pick yes yes
Suns are standard like that : so wasn't
it basically says to me that Philly I
had Zyra Smith number 10 on my board yes
basically Philly had him right there as
well right yeah but like but why him
over bridges my big question to be
honest is who's making these traits or
GM is the coach Brown they have a front
office they just don't have a GM leading
the front office who do you like more
Zaire Smith or McHale bridges I had
bridges at eight I believe and Ziya
Smith attend but they're right in that
same tier bridge is gonna turn 22 in
August desire Smith just turn 19 this
month and is a far better athlete and
just one of those guys where who knows
where he's gonna be in three years
you know I'm telling you you're gonna
love this guy he brings crazy balance
and energy one of those guys who impacts
games without needing dribbles and he
goes it brings the same level of
defensive intensity and defensive
versatility he's gonna be a fun player
to watch all right I'm excited Sunday
I'm just feeling a little bit suddenly I
feel good alright so zyre Smith Texas
Tech man I just wanted the local
Villanova kid to be playing for the
Sixers I was kind of hoping that was
gonna be a thing alright so have you
already given your grade for the Sixers
wait so we get a first-round pick for
this because I guess we're draining back
yeah yeah and it's one of Miami's picks
which they had gotten in the Goron
dragons deal gotcha
so 2021 eight so that yes the grades but
yes so they clearly valued bridges
pretty much the same way they did with
the Smith and Smith in terms of upside
in terms of theoretical upside yeah he
has more three years younger a better
athlete and chopped forty percent this
year from three what do you think about
bridges that on the Sun
great addition they needed defense they
had the worst defense in the league this
year they got their offense with Aidan
now to get their defensive piece to pair
their trio now is gonna be Booker
bridges and esri they'll also have to
figure out what to do with Josh Jackson
and TJ Warren two forwards we're gonna
probably play some small ball for
they're gonna play position with
basketball they're acquiring assets
there they got again their big offensive
cornerstone the number two with Devin
Booker and now they got a defensive
stopper around the perimeter all right
so we're gonna do is I hear Smith to the
Sixers even when Sam hinkie is not there
the Sixers love trading on draft night
they cannot help themselves right Terry
yeah awesome here Smith to the Sixers as
they trade back to 16 Sixers fans were
obviously excited that it seemed like
they took the local kid mikkel bridges
but now they trade back and they get a
guy that's three years younger and Zaire
Smith coming out of Texas Tech a guy
that was in your top ten I just don't
know who he is so who is he he is
arguably the best athlete in the draft I
mean he just poster eise's guys usually
you don't talk about two guards as being
Tiff's dunkers and not defensive
rebounds but when there's a miss he is a
threat to put it right back shot 40%
from behind the arc this year needs to
improve is off the dribble game and
creating but like I said before he just
turned 19 years old this month he's
shown flashes I think in workouts that
he could handle the ball a little bit
he's a good passer he just can't create
his shot overly well right now but give
him some time I mean this guy is loaded
with potential and everyone you talked
to about Cyrus Smith off the floor raves
about him a humble guy a hard worker who
was not ranked highly out of high school
I think everyone was gonna love him all
right so the Sixers went back a few
picks they also accumulated a future
2021 first-round pick from the Miami
Heat
factoring all that in which are great
for the pick this isn't hey like I said
before this was the number 10 player my
board and I think he's going to fig like
just like I swear I said about me Kyle
bridges I think Cyrus Smith's gonna fit
perfectly as a guy who can come in and
make an impact without needing the ball
in his hands and
he's gonna give them defense he's gonna
give them an injection of athleticism
into that lineup I think he could plan
at multiple spots the two of the three
it doesn't really matter in today's NBA
he's got really long arms even though
he's under sized put him in the game
he's gonna make plays he doesn't even
need his number called
man zyre Smith I was a little bit upset
at first that we didn't get bridges now
Johnny wass got me pumped about Zaire
excited Sixers get themselves the most
athletic player in the draft I could
sign with that oh all right you made me
feel a lot better yeah that was like
cathartic it felt good go watch a
highlight reel of him you'll you'll feel
much better YouTube I'm excited
all right so we are done 16 picks the
Milwaukee Bucks are currently on the
clock
it started off eight and what number one
Bagley what number two - whit number
three but then was traded to the
Mavericks
watch this is what professionals do the
Mavericks didn't sent back Trey young he
went to Atlanta quavo was super excited
for the Grizzlies they take jaren
Jackson junior some people call possibly
the top prospect in that draft six the
magic they take mo Bamba I don't need
less Bamba I need mo Bamba seven the
Bulls do Wendell Carter he believes
Johnny wass is the most polish and less
questions in the draft number eight the
Cavs take Collin Sexton you love that
pick Collin Sexton then put out there on
Twitter
LeBron let's do this let's go win a
championship number nine the Knicks take
Kevin Knox Knicks fans are booing Terry
Rozier says you're absolutely crazy
Kevin Knox is the guy to get it done
Sixers take Mikkel bridges at ten then
trade him to the Suns and they take
Zaire Smith as they come back SG a shy
gilja's alexander kentucky guard goes to
the hornets they trade into the Clippers
Clippers take Myles bridges send him
back to the Hornets Jerome Robinson goes
at number 13 to the Clippers Michael
Porter Jr we didn't know where he was
gonna fall goes to Denver at 14 could be
a value play could be a back issues for
years to come Troy Brown I think is the
surprise of the draft thus far going 15
- the Wizards and I've
already said Zaire Smith at the Sixers
and now who'll join Giannis
antetokounmpo at Number 17 overall the
Bucks are taking Dante D Vincenzo ah
another noble guy off the board this
time for real what do you think about
your bucks master oh I love my bucks man
oh they're making a great draft right
now it seemed to me like hey it's 30
teams with me on this side I really
liked your Celtics team bro but I just
can't get down with Boston that's my
like if you guys plan to any other city
but Boston I would've rock with y'all
heavy listen you ain't gotta explain a
question cuz I see you like some because
I you're Smith now we got DeAndre
without Luke on this side okay you got
your pigs down you got your pig down
back watering me yo same master
literally like after the Capitals won
the Stanley Cup he's like yo man I've
been wrong with the Capitals for a long
time the Eagles the Eagles when he came
to me said yo our Eagles did it man I
can't believe I was there for it man
else that was unbelievable I've been
waiting for that for a good five minutes
master who are your actual teams
I mean I grew up a big mass fan and then
when they won the Super Bowl though in
2011 it showed how worthless and the
return of investment is on being a
die-hard fan because their team the team
just was trashed at Super Bowl mouth
catching on everything would they wait
huh then one 2011 year what did he win
they beat you every to catch and
everything right now zone Hey it's not
working man it's a worth being a dollar
for $2 fan you already cut the dirt huh
oh yeah dirt dirt snow
first mr. Dargis rooting for Terry D way
oh you a lot and Sebastian lay do you
wait in a
those are the two and t-mac them three
top three favorite who were your three
that you were before growing up ciao
Sprewell ooh Alan Houston John Starks my
awesome New York easy straightening us
oh man that cool
I got a respected Ovid that's straight
in New York right there would watch it
all right we're gonna go to the pickaxe
my man we like hold on
so Yaran Weitzman no yaar own as he is
Rayleigh that's our own guy there Mikkel
bridges does not know yet that he's been
traded and he's still doing media in a
Sixers hat oh damn and as will be empty
suit rights know who's telling his mom
his mom was going nuts because she's
going my baby staying home he's staying
in Philadelphia and they're not
realizing that so you know we don't know
he's going to Phoenix that's tough he's
nice that's nice weather yeah but it's
not like your hometown nominee doesn't
know so is he from Philly or he just
went to Villanova that's a good point
someone were talking about your student
Ariel and he's from Philly
he's from Malvern problem Philly yeah
man you went to where Great Valley High
School never heard of it's not real the
whole before we get to Dante D Vincenzo
for the Bucks
who Howard who did you grow up who are
your favorite players when you grew up
give me things I know I'm old enough
that I could not have grown up on my job
no I grew up in the Bay Area when the
Warriors were absolute trash so there
was really no one to root for like I
remember when they had Joe Barry Carroll
I remember when they had Robert Parish
briefly before they traded him to the
Celtics wow really really long time ago
so no but I didn't have like NBA guys I
didn't have it because our local the
local angle was terrible the way
so you're just - do you support the
local yeah no I was a Niners got more
than anything okay I grew up on Joe
Montana that was my guy Joe Montana
Dwight Clark may he rest in peace yes
Jerry Rice Roger Craig Ronnie Lott man
those are my guys I grew up rooting for
Clarence Weatherspoon and then the
Sixers drafted Allen Iverson and then I
became the Allen Iverson fan like I'm
not gonna lie like you know everyone's
like oh I had the Jordan ones in the
Jordan 3's know I had the questions I
had the answers like I had every version
of affirmation I said where'd a little
finger little finger thing oh yeah get a
finger sleeve he started believer like
give me to ward was it's out three well
I was a huge Sixers fan so I'd say Allen
Iverson Matt Geiger and Tom McCullar
Yahoo that's why y'all though like
overall like in the rest of the league
Iverson was 100% in there I did not like
Kobe growing up but I liked him more
when I got older man all I liked was
Iverson ya know like I wrote it I write
or die with Iverson ok ok we'll get Jun
can't go wrong with that at all Juden
loves a Justin Bieber and 2 direction so
let's do I'm just gonna kick my ass no
he's not well Milwaukee Bucks will do
Donte D Vincenzo another Philly guy at
Villanova I'm excited I don't know what
you're gonna give you did your secret
grade thing so don t D Vincenzo to the
Bucs here we go in 3 2 1
Dante D Vincenzo lit up the n-c-double-a
championship and now he's going to Milly
walk a which was mentioned in Wayne's
wrong what do you think this value you
had him going at 19 he actually goes at
17 one of my favorite players in the
draft and I liked him before he dropped
31 in the national title game as you
could see here and you watch that game
he's one of those microwave guys who
catches fire and can score in bunches
but I think his best fitter are the
reason why he's gonna fit well in the
NBA as his backcourt versatility he
could be a playmaker he could be a
shooter he's a very pesky defender he's
a terrific athlete had the highest
vertical at the NBA combine it wasn't 42
inches whoa
so he could fly and he's just one of
those guys who didn't expect to be here
you interview him he's still living on
the cloud yeah and I really like those
type of players he's gonna be a very
good role player for a long time is the
sneaky athletic sorry it's something we
do for Caucasians great for Dante D
Vincenzo going at seven this isn't a
first of all I think Milwaukee needed
some back or help particularly at that
two guards spot I think Tony Snell has
been starting for them he doesn't give
them too much up D Vincenzo gives him a
little bit of everything like I said
he's a playmaker he's a shooter
he's a pesky defender he's gonna be able
to play to his strengths in Milwaukee
they got a couple scores in Middleton
and Yanis D Vincenzo can come in and
just play off the ball and and take what
the defense gives him and make plays off
the ball with his athleticism is passing
his shot making and they're gonna tell
him to defend around that perimeter and
we know that he could already perform on
the big stage don't they I like his last
name be Vincenzo to Milwaukee we'll see
if he's bucking it up with the Bucks
next season
all right so I know you guys get
scouting reports when we're talking
about the NFL we always left white pass
rushers they always say he's got a good
motor he hustles really hard and they
never say that about black athletes
right it's always he's athletic and
stuff do you see that in NBA scouting
reports too like his Matthew Dellavedova
is gritty and he's hustle there and all
that's knocked down over shooter right
but not really do you guys laugh about
it when you see that stuff probably
which are friends but not really so much
with the guys are on it yeah it's kind
of like usually everybody photos saying
yeah
well watch out Gordon Hayward sneaky
athletic don't tell anybody about it he
might he might done he might get you
he'll probably at the Sixers I have no
doubt none of my guys know so the Spurs
are up they are the team that people are
watching more for Kawhi Leonard than
anything I feel like you know the Spurs
pretty well back and I'm curious they've
been they've had Tony Parker and Manu
Ginobili and all these guys for so long
this feels like their first real
transition how do you think they're
gonna handle it well we didn't really
know when the last transition happened
because it was so subtle because they
picked up Kawhi Leonard in a draft day
trade flipping George Hill for what the
15th pick in the draft is Kawhi Leonard
became their next franchise guy and
might still be by the way if there's
anything that I do know about the Spurs
or think I know they're they're not
making hasty decisions they're not going
to make a deal with Kawhi just for the
sake of placating him if they believe
there's any way to patch this up they
don't have to trade him like yes there's
a risk that he could walk away as a free
agent next summer but he's under
contract for the coming year there are
no holdouts in the NBA you know it's a
direct contract you you would get fired
you will lose pay every day so it's not
like he's not gonna show up he could
show up unhappy but I think they'll do
everything possible to try to resolve
this first because he was an MVP
candidate only a year ago and you you
don't just squander that and you don't
make a bad deal they'll they'll they'll
try to hold on to this but your question
is interesting to Adam and just that you
know Tony Parker managed to nobly you
know Manu is under contract for next
year Tony Parker is not they both could
just retire yeah we'll see where this
goes and if they do have a trade Kawhi
I don't know are they are they holding
place are they getting veterans to just
kind of keep going and patch it up
around the Marcus Aldridge or are they
saying now is when we take a step back
and the attic in the draft tonight maybe
as part of the next era and this pop
water go along for all that we'll find
out master June who are the Spurs taken
is 17 and number 18 or 18 number 18
overall the Spurs are selecting Lonnie
Walker the rules are probably because
the Spurs are so good draft in June who
are your three favorite basketball
players growing up growing up Paul
Pierce terrible start
Steve Nash and LeBron I guess you can't
I guess the LeBron I'm the master he was
who's the Boston rivals so go bro LeBron
James Dirk Nowitzki
Paul Pierce though no Paul Pierce got my
father a player got my heart forever uh
who owes who are you LeBron James Dirk
and I was a big I wasn't a big Kobe fan
at the time but I think I think looking
back on retrospect in his career
handicar I hated Kobe too but like I
think now I am a much bigger Kobe fan
looking back on his career than I was at
the time yes that's who we got that's
what fandom does to you man it really
like because I was a mass fan I couldn't
really enjoy Kobe Bryant during his
career yeah but once you kind of get out
of that you really admire like what Kobe
was capable I just have blinders on the
entire time with with Kobe just like
he's on the Lakers everyone thinks he's
better than Jordan which he's not like
but so you had the big three in Boston
why did you like Paul Pierce over
because the oh geez there since he was
there since since the old days so he was
the main guy there before kg got there
so we mean it was always my guy yeah I
don't know I was like you guys I I hated
Kobe so much growing up and then like
towards the end when he really embraced
being like an a-hole I was like yes like
embrace the evil embrace the dark side
please all right Lonnie Walker going to
the Spurs I know that you like this pick
a lot don't tell me about it
we're going to do the video but this is
a kid out of Miami that I don't think a
lot of people have seen he's young and
you had him going before this so this
would be a good pic Kalani Walker the
Spurs let's do some
action we are not sure what era of Spurs
basketball were going to get but it
seems right now that Lonnie Walker will
be a part of the future what are they
getting in San Antonio Lonnie upside
this is the first time in a while that
they've drafted a guy with this much
upside he's one of the top athletes in
the draft and I don't see I don't think
he got to really show his full potential
at Miami came in midway through after
injury and then Bruce Brown goes down
and he kind of had to carry a workload
that he wasn't ready for so it wasn't
the best environment to really showcase
himself but as you see this guy is a
big-time explosive athlete but also a
very good looking shooter forgetting the
percentages 34 percent from downtown
he's a much better to her than the
numbers suggest now he's got to improve
his off the dribble game and creating
his own shot but I think he's a
secondary playmaker somebody if you give
him a ball screen he can make things
happen we'll see where he takes the rest
of his game but his foundation shooter
athlete you atom going maybe 16 he
actually goes 18 what's your grade get
him at that spot I give it a b-plus I
don't think he's gonna be ready to go
right now he actually kind of reminded
me of Jalen Brown coming out of college
oh where you could see the talent but
maybe college wasn't the best fit for
him again to showcase his skills and a
more open NBA let him get down the floor
they'll have more open shots they'll
have to do less on the ball and
obviously San Antonio management Darrin
coaches their studs with developing
their young players oh yeah also a very
bright young kid if you talk to him so I
like to pick here this late I thought he
would go higher well when you tell me
that someone has a lot of potential and
then I find out that they're going to
the Spurs I imagine he's going to reach
his potential Loni Walker that they get
18 to San Antonio so with all of that
hair how do they measure his actual
height I don't agree with his hair it's
not some of my favorite hair in the
league you don't agree with this hair
don't agree it's going in too many
directions I guess it does give him
advantage Tecna can you just pull up the
graphic as of his hair I want Terry to
see it too it's not Alfred Payton it's
not the weekend it's it's a it's a head
explosion
right on the top what what do you think
Terry I mean I wouldn't rocket we're
kind of weird but I mean maybe yeah
Samba handi or maybe you think is cool
but I don't like it maybe about that
picture no it's a dick much if it's
visually confusing to the defender ooh
maybe that kind of helps you out a
little misdirection no I was just saying
though like okay right so his height is
listed there at six or five how do they
know he's six foot five how do you know
where the top of his head starts do you
stick like a war inside the hair and
then go okay so we're gonna subtract
from the top of the hair you may be
overthinking this just I'm clearly
overthinking this yes all right so it's
not out for Payton but wasps does not
agree with the hair give him a b-plus I
give his hair D Oh harsh grader lean I
just not a fan all right so I want to go
over your big board really quick the one
guy that has not been taken that you had
a little bit higher was Kevin her of
Maryland after that on your big board
Robert Williams from Texas A&M the
center that you said is a good defensive
stopper than Aaron holiday younger
brother I believe of Jay
holiday I like him do you you've seen
him many of them two years now oh and
then Josh a Koji from Georgia Tech but
Kevin herder has not gone yet what our
team's missing what who is Kevin hurt
her one of the best shooters in the
draft and this was a guy who nobody
really knew much about coming in I mean
we knew him but we didn't know how good
he was and he shows up to the NBA
combine and he just really stands out in
fact he shut it down the second day
because he was so good on that first day
six seven sighs but he's more than just
a shooter I know he gets the Kyle Korver
comparisons but you have it's three and
a half assists he can create a little
bit and create his own shot as well and
though not a physical defender he's a
smart defender in placed team defense I
think that's gonna really build well for
him at the next level he's gonna fit in
anywhere he goes it'll be interesting to
see who actually pulls the trigger
Howard now that we're a team up I was
gonna go to you do you have anything you
want to say before we go to the young
guys oh go for it okay young guys before
June announces this pink
shout outs are be our social moments
team because they always really capture
basketball culture
a 1 a 1 graphic here they Photoshop over
the young thug gunner epic pictures
that's been going viral and put and they
got to change football over the to and
waiting to be drafted like it's this is
classic is gonna be the best photo shot
best basketball culture draft moment
that you're gonna yeah hold on don't
announce the pic pull that back up cuz I
don't think Terry even realized that
that was fake for a second yeah look
Terry is taking a picture of our city
back Terry it is available on Twitter
and Instagram so you could do it there
[Laughter]
so Terry as you can see in the back you
have lamelle oh you have Lee Angelo and
that was the young thug picture what was
young thug doing in that photo why did
that become gun as part of YSL records
this way young thug obviously owns so
yunk that was kind of like serving as
his big brother min so I don't know what
exactly was going on in this specific
picture yes but I can only assume the
young cub was mentor and gonna over some
very Terry what do you got my man I like
you a lot I'm gonna help you out on this
one
you saw what happen that wasn't gonna
the in the in the picture of dirt was a
little dirt okay I thought I was gonna
the whole time a little dirt okay cool
they look kind of similar there you know
but that's Lee Angelo a lot of guys in
the rap game look up to young thug so
that's how it work yeah I ran with it if
it gives a great picture to run with for
it to be like you know to go viral and
stuff like that but yeah a lot of people
look up the young thug so you know
that's our country when I saw that for
not like that I get you I get you let's
let's go to our local hip-hop flavor the
month story and Howard Beck thoughts on
the young thug picture and it's sort of
what we have there
I mean clearly it's the best meme of the
day you know it really it really touches
on a lot of the you know cultural
moments that are happening as we sit
here yeah yeah
back to you Adam thanks
I will say this though young thug is one
of the few guys right now that puts out
projects that you don't know what it's
gonna sound like and I appreciate that
he's either gonna go country he's gonna
be singing you have no idea Abid young
thug I have abilities
alright June we're ready for your
seriousness all right so with the with
the number 19 overall pick Atlanta is
zeroing in on Kevin herder of Maryland
according to whoo oh there we go
zeroing in we haven't heard that one I
feel like we need to get a like an
actual graphic of all the world's words
that which is used zeroed in I think
it's the second time he's easier than
this coughing arouse key accounts having
a lot of fun oh dude he's nailing it all
right so it's actually funny we just
talked about her then the fact that we
know that we're teaming him up with Trey
young yeah all of a sudden Atlanta's
bombs away
they're shooting from all over the place
what what grain you're gonna be giving
this I'm gonna give it a man I'm gonna
give it an A I really liked her I said
he's gonna fit in anywhere and now he's
got a point guard to get him the ball he
didn't really have that at Maryland now
he does and I think it works out for
Atlanta they need shot-makers to
surround young with Young's gonna do a
lot of penetrating a lot of very shifty
gets into the lane and I was got someone
to kick it out to and her like we said
before is one of the best shooters in
this draft over 40% again and so I'm a
fan he was one of my top players what do
you as a franchise this is interesting
so Travis Lake who's is the GM they're
been there in that job for a year came
from the Warriors who as we know that
evolution began with the splash brothers
right before everything else came along
we had Steph and klay I'm not saying by
any stretch saying that that's what
they're saying
I'm not make a headline Howard but it
does seem you know I do the broad
strokes here that travis ranked at a
minimum you could say is trying to
whether it's recreate that or just
simply create in the mount in the mold
of that this is a modern looking young
NBA team we're gonna go with three-point
shooting and get up and down the court
yeah there
coach Lloyd Pierce came from the Sixers
who they're often very much very modeled
after patterned after a lot of what the
words we're doing again spread the floor
three-point shooters get up and down so
interesting that the the pics they've
made tonight kind of follow that dem old
I think it's so rare for actual
professional franchises and it's crazy
that it's rare to actually have a vision
and then execute that vision and the
coach that they got from the Sixers when
you really watch the Sixers down the
stretch he was the one calling the
out-of-bounds place calls he was like
coaching the team down the stretch when
I found out that he was leaving the
Sixers I went damn like I felt like he
was actually our coach down the street a
long time player development guy very
well-respected around the league also
hails from San Jose so shout out to San
Jose you home are you alright
all right let's do Kevin herder to the
Atlanta Hawks the new splash brothers
according to Howard back Kevin herder
and Trey young you heard it here first
front page New York Times and bleacher
report all right let's do it
Kevin herder to the Hawks not the
Falcons do you hear that noise it's the
sounds of Nets being ripped across
Atlanta they already got Trey young now
it's Kevin herder tell them what they
need to know about this kid because
you're very impressed he was number 14
on my board so to get them in 19 you
know you're gonna get a good grade you
could just look at the stroke and just
one of those very convincing shooting
strokes and maybe a better athlete than
giving credit for maybe not a dunker but
another mobile agile uses his feet
really well can create his own shot
better than you'd think based on his
role at Maryland has a floater to his
game knows how to score within the
offense and I didn't say this but there
have been others who have said he is a
poor man's klay Thompson yeah and so you
get the poor man Steph Curry with Trey
young and the poor man's herder at poor
man's klay Thompson with herder and you
can clearly see that they're trying to
recreate something that was from Golden
State and yeah he's a shot maker at
worst comes to worst
alright well they're not poor
longer so maybe they'll make some money
and make up to Stephan clay you're great
for getting about this pick at number 19
I give it a like I said he was 14 on my
board they get him at 19 I think he
feels a whole Torian prince is a nice
player but I think he's play harder at
the two at the three maybe of the small
ball four as a six seven guy in today's
league and like I said before tre young
is gonna get into the paint a lot he
needs somebody to kick it out to her
there's gonna be a knock-down guy and I
think also Collins is loving this too
all of a sudden the court just opened up
big-time new coach kind of a new GM are
they the new splash brothers I don't
care if they're poor men they're still
men hurt her young the new gunnars for
the Atlanta Hawks red head didn't want
to say in the video how many redheads
are in the NBA well when we had we had
Matt Bonner but he's obviously retired
red Mamba
it's Cal yeah retired an actual redhead
in the NBA this is crazy I didn't think
they existed anymore teri you know
really I don't know so - yeah I've never
seen it so to me Kevin herders the
perfect kind of guy that Jalen Brown at
Summer League is like this guy's gonna
guard me this redhead got right like
talk so much in summer league yeah if
you go here you go guys you gotta have
some game so right behind that right
here you got to back it up and you got
it you gotta you gotta or it could mean
that his shot is so on fire let's see
let's hope let's hope we don't have a
lot of danger browsers out there who's
Chinese right I am excited though for
red-headed people across the country and
the world be Kevin hurt her I mean like
look art Jordan our photographer here
big redhead he got to be super excited
for this see he's not gonna claim
redhead but that's what redheads do they
don't admit that they're red hair all
right Howard what do you think we're 19
picks in right now anything surprising
you anything you're looking forward to
nothing is surprising I think what's
interesting right now is that after all
the you know chatter and Buzz
about the idea this was gonna be a
really active draft in terms of trades
the only trade so far have been other
draft picks yes and we have not seen
anything involving active players that
who were the active players that you
were hearing could possibly be traded
well I mean the the most likely one it
seems tonight would have been Chandler
Parsons because it was going to be in
concert with a pic right aside from that
you know there was always the outside
chance of Kawhi Leonard I never thought
that I would think so either
today but I just think that with so many
teams in a position where there's either
some amount of desperation or a need to
kind of hit the reset button you know
that this is this is the kind of draft
with as much fluidity as there was that
maybe you start to see some of the
veterans thrown in there too yeah
Toronto may want to break things up they
may send out Kyle Lowry that's that's
you know been kind of rumors over there
that those things don't have to happen
in concert with the draft but certainly
a year ago we saw a lot of that
happening I will also say that we've
really only had one guy outside of your
top 19 go your you have nailed the 19 so
props to you we're gonna toss over there
for the pic but before we go I want to
know your guess
Minnesota at 20 who do you think they
took and then June will tell you if
you're right or wrong
Wow who do I think they took I'm gonna
guess at this point do you put Robert
Williams next to karl-anthony towns I
think they take him as the best player
available right now that would be my
guess if they're making the pick I've
heard that they've been looking to move
down earlier in the night I'm not sure
what's going on but Robin Williams would
be the best player on my board yes Aaron
Holliday from UCLA Josh Akagi from
Georgia Tech Chandler Hutchison is a
sneaky play right here I would go with
one of those four ok I'm from Minnesota
all right Jun was he right at number 20
overall the Timberwolves are selecting
Joshua Kochi Josh a Koji Georgia Tech
shooting guard under 20 years old also
though we hey what do you got the load
bombs he has used quite the verbage in
his tweets today oh this is perfect it's
really hitting up a source calm we've
got locked in on selecting focused on
selecting zeroing in on prefers has been
focused on is
targeting has been seriously considering
cleared the way to choose is locked on
is determined to select are fixated on
has zeroed in on and have no plans to
pass was that the last one they have no
plans to pass on Utah Jazz have no plans
to pass on Grayson Allen with the 21st
pick wow that's the next okay that's
that is that is brilliant have no
remember remember he was a writer before
he wasn't right so let me let's go
behind the curtain really quick to the
media world do you think that the ESPN
brass pulls in watch and goes what what
the hell did the ESPN brass moved heaven
and earth a year ago and payloads a lot
of money to be this guy if they expected
anything other than that that's crazy
that's like think the MPA Rozier and
asking him not to shoot like that that
was good
do you think the NBA hits up ESPN and
goes what the hell there's going to be
some conversations but you know the woge
is their their NBA franchise right now
in terms of their NBA news breaking to
yes and you didn't acquire him to be
silent on draft night this is who he is
this is this is his brand that's what he
brought so yeah you know I by curiosity
would be more and we will we will not we
will not know this we will not find this
out my curiosity would be more
did he tell his bosses ahead of time
listen guys I can't I you know I can't
do this yeah tell the NBA whatever you
got to tell them I still got to do what
I do or is you're actually truly going
rogue right I would love it I hope he is
going road all I know is I have no plans
to pass on doing this a koji video so we
have to do it because I have no plans to
pass I'm zeroing in on a Koji right now
to Minnesota and I'm targeting it and
I'm really focused on selecting a koji
right now but I will say that grace and
Alan to the Utah Jazz is the most a Utah
pick ever hey is there a white guy that
could fit in here perfect get them oh we
went to Duke even better our fans will
love them all right we'll get that's a
second
Minnesota is a team with a really good
young core they minute to the playoffs
they have high hopes and now they're
adding Josh a Koji from Georgia Tech
kids not 20 years old yet what are they
getting in Minnesota he's gonna step in
for a Jamal Crawford didn't that bench
scoring role and he can get buckets from
all over the place and I'll admit he
overlooked him during the season I see
him at the NBA combine and he was one of
those guys who just clearly stood out
and I promise you he improved his stock
in those two days there in Chicago a
really aggressive athletic slasher to
the basket but as a developing mid-range
game can stop and pop can shoot the
three-ball really long arms he's maybe
six four but has around a seven-foot
winks while so he's gonna be able to
guard ones twos maybe even threes I
think he's gonna be a nice player for
them maybe not right away but somebody
that they're gonna develop as a weapon
off the bench
you had him going around 21 he actually
goes 20 so props to you what is your
grade for going to this fun I give it a
I forget what I gave it I think I gave
her the B+ there you go and listen this
is a I'm excited about his upside it may
take him some time to get there but I
really like this kid after watching him
at the combine I went back and watched
more film and I just I missed him and I
think a lot of people did as well he was
not somebody I heard mentioned from
Scouts during the season but clearly
this is a big-time athlete with big-time
scoring potential and defensive
versatility he was not heard of much to
her in the season but going number 20
and playing for Minnesota he wants to be
heard now Josh tukoji the pick for the
Timberwolves at bent day number 20 guys
it's important to get like you know all
the languages you know Spanish speaking
English speaking alright I'm sure you've
seen Grayson Allen the kid from Duke
he's been known to be a little bit of a
flopper he's been known to kind of like
kick people and punch people and
whatever have you seen anything about
Grayson what do you know about Grayson
Allen he might do an insult Grayson
Allen I mean I've seen a lot of I seen a
lot of his his low act outs where he was
pointed against Louisville a bunch II
like Zazu you do I do
how come
I mean it just shows his greed his fight
and all that it's gonna take him a long
way you just got to control it a little
bit but no I like it all right hold on
I'll make the game work fine oh yes
don't try to be you're so professional
I've tried it with the right person
Terry Rozier the Celtics you go to Utah
in comes Grayson Allen and one of those
little choked kick things happen how you
gonna handle that do you it's not hey
you're gonna make sure it doesn't have
no I make sure it don't happen I think
he gonna make sure you know happened
here you go would you say something for
teammate don't even think about it
nah but if he was a dude guy he regret
it
yeah I'm not waiting to react react
right away I'm really getting the
feeling that you next year
now that like everyone knows that you're
for real is game on don't comment you
don't step to you his game mama talk my
stuff will be me i'ma have fun I'm you
know I'm play ball but I'm gonna be a
little bit more out here oh yeah a
little bit more make it more interesting
I'm not gonna have Twitter fingers like
Joel and B but your guy but it's gonna
be interesting he's gonna be just to see
what the things I do and say I like it
trash talk yeah what do you think about
Grayson Allen it's a hard guy to root
for yeah I would imagine you know if
you're a player like Terry like he's the
guy that you want on your team doing
that to your opponent not necessarily
the guy who's doing that stuff to you
yes you look at him a little bit
differently depending on on where he is
that stuff probably won't fly very well
in the NBA I think he probably will have
to check ups so I have a conspiracy
theory that Utah always takes the white
guy do other people in the NBA feel this
way Becker am I just being weird there's
you know maybe a little bit of a history
there but I don't think that currently
that that's been in recent years odd
looking so much I mean Boston had that
reputation too and that I mean I feel
like that's fallen by the wayside yeah
all right I'm gonna look it up later cuz
it's a good theory that I have
pretty good you've already given your
your grade or half okay let's do it I'm
gonna stop creating controversy it's
kind of what I do - June agrees with me
no he's shaking his head all right let's
do Grayson Allen go number 21 - the Utah
Jazz oh yes you have seen this guy for
all those years at Duke a lot of people
thought after his freshman year maybe
should come out there weights a little
bit Grayson Allen - the Jazz what do you
think about him going at this spot cuz I
know you had of a lot lower yeah this
was uh I felt a little bit of a reach
but obviously Utah like what he brings
to the table and it's pretty obvious
what he brings he's a shot maker he hit
over 80 threes in three straight seasons
I think that's gonna be his signature at
the NBA level come off the bench spot up
around the arc run off screens knock
down jumpers and he's a pretty good
athlete get out in transition and get
yourself easy baskets and I think he
helped himself during interviews I think
there was obviously a bad perception of
him around the league because of the
flopping incidents because of the
tripping incidents because of the mental
breakdowns but if you talk to him you
realize you know what this guy isn't so
bad we'll see how he fits in with Utah's
locker room we'll see how he fits in
with Donovan Mitchell but clearly they
valued his shot making great for the pic
and just how he fits with that jazz
roster I give it a B - I think his role
is pretty clear come off the bench and
put the ball in the basket he was a
little bit inconsistent at Duke and that
worries me a little bit he actually had
his best season when he had the ball in
his hands the most and then when he was
put around guys like Tatum this year and
Ingram last year I should say and then
this year all those guys with Bagley and
Carter he kind of struggled with
inconsistency so is he gonna need the
ball a lot now or can he be a
complementary guy who doesn't need all
the dribbles and so that's what's gonna
be the interesting thing as how does he
fit but clearly he's gonna be a six-man
spark microwave type guy who comes off
the bench Utah really did impress a lot
of people we'll see if Grayson can add
to their run and maybe they can get over
the hump in the Western Conference
Grayson Allen now part of the Utah Jazz
all right June why were you shaking your
head at me earlier the Boston thing it's
just uh yeah it's it's a reputation that
I wish I wish that they could shake
toothpicks for you guys so at number 22
overall the Bulls selection or Chandler
Hutchinson and at number 23 overall the
Indiana Pacers select Aaron holiday all
right
so yet again is sticking right to your
your mold here Terry why don't you like
Herod holiday he's going to the Pacers I
like him a lot
do you really sign a watchdog get it
done not going back down
you know that's dumb type of things
stand out especially when you when you
have got that that went through college
and playing in a league and you see you
see the younger guys play is just like
you can sail like when the guy yes got
that edge and he the Pacers and I feel
like that is the Pacers is the dog
interesting that's gonna be that's gonna
be yes that's a nice fit for much yes a
good fit there by Terry good draft
analysis yeah ain't no Celtics rating
over steel hey alright so Chandler
Hutchinson Aaron holiday before we kind
of get into these videos just a little
thing on each of those guys arson 20
points to game this season Boise State
so you didn't get to see him a ton at
the national level didn't didn't play
too many games against quality opponents
but just one of those guys who aces the
I test
six seven sighs a big-time athlete looks
the part of an NBA score was always a
jump shot away I kind of always said he
might be the Kyle Kuzma of this year's
draft do you find out you know he's
actually better Schumer save it for the
video
let's do Chandler Hutchinson right now
what did you say what do you say pal
kuzmic how cool a draft like this like
far is what like shoots you know there's
a guy who slips late in the season
oh you got a little insulted there huh
no I mean I'm I'm still learning a guy I
know I don't know it's you know listen
this video about Chandler Hutchinson and
then you give your scouting report after
he gives his scouting report all right
let's do it
I love this I think this is funny I
guess I'm learning right here along with
Terry this is good all right Chandler
Hutchinson going to doubles
we are at the part of the draft where
you're hoping to find someone that slips
pic number 22 and you believe that this
could be the guy Boise State never seen
him
Chandler Hutchinson explain who this man
is I've had the Bulls taking us in for
probably about a month now I think they
need a wing and he kind of fits the
exact type of player that they could use
like I said before I test stand out just
looks the part big time transition
player attacks downhill has the NBA size
was always a jump shot away you know
never had that free ball this year he
kind of added at one point five threes
per game that's a career-high needs to
improve in the mid-range in terms of
creating his own shot with the pull-up
with the floater but he can attack get
to the basket he could shoot the three
in guard a couple positions all right so
I would like your grade and then also
factoring in him and Wendell Carter now
on this team together do they work in
tandem sure I think they both start from
day one Oh Ross I believe with this is a
b-plus by the way you have marketing you
have wind out car out front Hutchinson
slides a lot of big three spot I don't
know if they're gonna bring back Zach
Lavine but Chris done there so now they
have field holes at all their positions
and he's one of the older guys in the
draft four years of college and he's
gotten better every single year now that
he's got this three ball down I think
he's got a chance to be a steal in this
draft and I said before he could be the
Kyle Kuzma of this draft because he was
a little bit undervalued maybe because
of the three-point shooting percentage
you find out in the NBA maybe he's not
so bad from outside yeah 22 years old
again joining Wendell Carter Hutchinson
could be a name that Bulls fans are
cheering for a long long time now let's
go to Terry for his review Terry what do
think about Chandler Hutchinson I think
he's pretty good all right yeah you
can't show enough clip for me to you
know make that final decision but he
looks pretty good that's crossover to
the dunk the change of direction what
I'm saying he liked that it was good
right him going over there with Bobby
Portis he made a statement you think he
gonna start like what's gonna happen
with that I think if they need a small
floor who's their starting small forward
oh he's a small okay it's it's zipser or
no
was a restricted by the beans a
restricted free agent and you know that
I think there is a legit question about
like how much are you willing to invest
to bring back Zach Lavine you know I
think the Bulls have to start figuring
out how to sort out what they've got
right now and they've got up to 41
million dollars in capital this summer
but a lot of that disappears depending
on how much you're paying Olivia I mean
I think they're going to resign Lavine I
imagine that at this point just months
removed yet I'm returning from the ACL
they don't have to max him out I would
think all right so this is the question
that Terry was asking and let's figure
this out so they bring in Wendell Carter
and Chad Hutchinson Chandler Hutchinson
how did that you see this call with
Robin Lopez and Bobby Portis there on
the bench - well I guess Lopez starts
and maybe I jumped the gun a little bit
with Wendell Carter starting right away
I assume Lopez starts if he's still
there they don't train them in marketing
and then you have Portis off the bench
as well so they have a lot of bigs now
now they have depth now they have depth
and you know sometimes it takes some
time for these guys to develop yeah the
look the Bulls made a surprise run for a
lot of teams last year kind of early on
showing a little bit of potential but
both of those guys just what sticks in
my head is you saying Wendell has no
questions and then Hutchinson's the one
that could be the kuzmin of the draft
seems like a pretty good draft of
Chicago
let's do Terry's guy Aaron Holliday
going to the Pacers me and wasps are
gonna break it down we'll let Terry
watch the highlights and then wax poetic
about our Drew's younger brother is
gonna be an absolute dog for the
Indianapolis Pacers you already know sip
that Cup let's go
Aaron house
everybody saw what the Pacers did in the
first round give it a little bit of fear
to those Cavaliers we're now in the
first one the draft Aaron Holliday a guy
that I know some people think is a dog
with a lot of fight what do you think
about Aaron Holliday big fan I think
this is this is their new starting point
guard to the future no disrespect to
Darren Collison who's been very easy and
steady but Matt Holliday gets it done at
both ends talked by he was only 6 1
because 187 pounds
that's more than Trey that's more than
Shea that's more than Sexton gets
downhill can attack the basket but shot
over 40% from downtown in three straight
years that jump shot gives him a high
floor he's going to make them from
outside and he's gonna pressure you on
defense you're great for this pick
and you've already gets City who's gonna
be the starter so that's pretty exciting
for Pacers maybe not right away I give
him a name I a - here I guess we have
the degrade a little bit missed up but I
am is for me I think he's a future
starting point guard and to get him at
number 21 for all that's good value to
me he may not start right away with cows
in there but cautions entering the final
year on this deal
we got a review of the video graphics
were messed up we're gonna blame Sean
McManus look there's a thing in this
industry where usually the people on
camera take it Sean I'm just kidding I
love Sean's the man 23 overall Aaron
holiday I see the dog I see that going
to the basket with the offhand throwing
it up and all that stuff and then for
you that I didn't know hardest thing
when it comes to evaluating draft guys
is you have one year but when you have
three years of a guy shooting 40% then
you go he's a shooter he's a shooter
come he stepped in for Alonzo ball and
yeah averaged 20 and 6 all right let's
do the video getting Sean again I'm only
kidding it was actually my fault I'll
take the play my I said in that graphic
that was my fault apologize
the Pacers we saw a lot of fight out of
this team in the first round of playoffs
and they're getting a fighter in the
first round this draft Aaron Holliday
older brothers Drew we've seen him
what makes this kids so dynamic and go
in the first round so tough so skilled
over 40% from downtown in all three
years at UCLA this year he averaged over
20 a game and nearly six assists turns
the ball over a little bit too much but
not a big deal
scores at the basket clearly can shoot
the ball and defensively he's tough he
gets up in your grille and makes like
difficult in terms of grade to get him
at the 23rd pick you had him right
around 20 so the values there what's
your grade for getting it at the spot a
- I think he's got the chance to be
their starting point guard of the future
and maybe Darren Collison holds it down
for one more year but long term they're
gonna give the ball to Holliday and like
I said before he plays both ends he
gives you a little more firepower than
Collison does and I'm a big fan of his
jump shot i buy it seen it for three
straight years the guy could clearly
score great reputation in terms of his
defense in terms of his ability to dig
in an opposing point guards strong build
I'm offense I think he's he's the future
there and the backcourt a lot of people
say it's kind of easy to find point
guards but if you can find the one the
draft and then build around him sounds
like this guy might be the guy it is now
a holiday in Indy Pacers take an errand
in the first round all right so no Terry
you like that kid what does it meet like
what is the advantage of having an older
brother already in the NBA - - okay so -
what's the advantage of finding two
older brothers in the NBA I mean I think
it's a big help I mean out I wouldn't
know how I feel but you got guys that
that been through it all so they can
help you adjust they can you know talk
to you obviously seem like them three
guys it's pretty close both his older
brothers at the draft with him so I mean
I think it's a big time for him and I
think it's great yeah not too many guys
have two older brother that's already in
the lead I was gonna say there has to be
so many life adjustments that they can
help you out with yeah because it's a
lot of things you got to learn when you
come
so the league is not easy so what are
the things you have to learn the let it
out Keep Calm the time you spin off the
court the things you know just how
important it is being a pro of being a
professional of learning the game and
stuff like that I'm pretty sure they can
they can help me and give them the
blueprint at least how to start off you
know you can't tell it tell a person how
to be himself in the in the league you
said that a few times you said being a
pro what does that mean to you to be a
pro as it goes different between it's
different between the college and the
NBA when you a pro you getting up so
many reps shots you you doing stuff on
your own is becoming a professional
taking care of your body getting
massages developing the routine and
stuff like that that's that's that's
when you know when you're a pro when you
taking care of your body like every day
you know you got guys like I see other
guys like I'll and stuff like that and
they do the same stuff and it's just
making them comfortable and how how they
can be successful and what they do and
that's becoming a pro and he got his
older brothers that that can help him
give him that so he's gonna come in he's
already gonna get his routine down
understand life on the road I think you
gonna get a great understanding he's
gonna develop his every every person is
different even if he's got two brothers
in the league he's gonna he gonna find a
way to do his own thing but he's still
gonna have guys his two older brothers
to tell him like you know I feel like he
could talk to him and help him out a
little bit that's awesome big-time not
too many guys have to quota brothers
playing the league no I think nobody I
don't think anybody do so all right we
met master Jun I heard the ding in my
ear what does that mean so whoa just
channeling his inner Jack Jack from
being critical Incredibles because at
number 24 overall Portland has quote a
laser on Efrain assignments sounds
painful also we also want to go back
real quick Lonnie Walker already was
drafted by my San Antonio Spurs he's got
this big hair and when he was it's just
the Hat he's rocking it like flies
that's a look you see the plows look
don't you Terry yes
but about beyond algae with that wait
wait put that back up cuz this is the
guy that we were talking about his hair
for like five minutes right and this is
the hat city we were talking about for
about five I was that's fantastic oh my
god what do you guys say plies yeah you
can't run on game when I'm girl with
that I don't know you're right that's
that's going in the all-time NBA draft
archive like right up there were like
Jalen Rose's suit yes and that's no hair
and it makes it even better
yes there it is Lonnie Walker's hair I
remember Alfred Payton was funny wearing
his hat who was the one that the magic
took I went last year
Jonathan Isaac Jonathan Isaac had all
the hair to his hat was up alright so
you just gave your grade was it anferny
simmons was at Simon's silence Afridi's
Simon's shooting guard he is going to
Portland
because Portland needs shooting guards I
thought they'd have a lot of those you
can never have enough shooting in this
league Adam not parently alright so
we're gonna break this down wasps do you
like this kid thumbs up or thumbs down I
do a medium you're you're lukewarm on
him so the one guy that I'm seeing that
has not gone in your top is Robert
Williams and I think you kind of expect
a little bit the shot blocker out of
Texas A&M
yeah Williams still on the board one of
the top big men athletes in the draft
one of the top rim protectors but you
know he's really got to fill the clint
capela type role as a lob catcher
finisher and shot blocker because he has
zero skill so maybe that's why also two
years at Texas A&M he hasn't shown any
improvement whatsoever so that's a
problem I just saw Howard Beck's cell
phone so let's see what that means but
mostly because I'm laughing and I just
can't resist sharing this because this
is what we do with social media whoa
geez latest reports not tipping a pic
simply saying that a source says the
Lakers are unlikely to resist Mwanga
it's it really is a masterclass in
avoiding your boss's words right now I
was on his face as he's doing this over
at Barclays Center I assume he is there
I could just imagine him just
like laughing his butt off as he's
sending these out
yeah just for your information it's
vogner okay yeah I don't want to correct
you know but I'm like Terry I catch a
little I know somebody gonna catch me if
I thought me so so I'm waiting for you
to mess I already know how to correct a
lot of no all right so let's do Portland
and for any Simon's yes Simon's who
Wasserman's lukewarm about
yeah he's kiddie pool starting up your
shower
he's Brita before it's been in the
refrigerator all right okay I'm ready
the Blazers with their first pick in the
NBA Draft 24th overall going with
Anfernee Simon's educate me educate
Portland fans what are they getting he's
the only guy they worked out twice they
brought him in right at the last second
Simon's coming straight from high school
as a fifth year well a graduate student
so you didn't get to see him at the
college level I scouted him live in
Springfield back in January and he had a
big game that game he's very skinny he's
very Rob but but also skilled he could
shoot the ball you can create shots for
himself he's six three and he's not a
point guard he is a scorer so he's gonna
have to be a low Williams type
undersized at the two guard position can
he defend can he get others involved and
is he gonna be able to score against NBA
caliber athletes it's really anybody's
guess I was not expecting to see video
of that grade high school kid
interesting
what is your grade for this pick and if
you're getting them out of high school
the ceilings got to be high what kind of
ceiling a [ __ ] yeah he's still a
teenager I give it a b-minus because
there's somebody sitting on the board
that I thought would have been the
perfect fit and that's Kyrie Thomas from
Creighton there's a three and D guy
behind there too already big-time
scorers in the backcourt so I guess they
just loved the long-term potential with
Simons and couldn't resist he's not
gonna be ready next year he's gonna need
time either in the G League or on the
bench but clearly you take him for the
upside he's a teenager he's athletic and
he can score ma'am all right look
Portland they're stashing them young
we'll see if he can develop Anthony
Simon's right from the IMG
you see what he can do in the Pacific
Northwest man so what was the line that
that he used for the Lakers that they
were unlikely to resist unlikely to
resist and then what was it for Anfernee
silence lasering in on has a laser has a
laser on yeah Wow
art form what do you got us first June
good no pic weeks at the current moment
we have this quote from Kevin Knox to
ESPN though yeah Ian Begley tweeted this
out he said on the television interview
with ESPN there's your boy Kevin Knox
Terry Fox pan out real quick he said
that Kevin Knox says I'm getting booted
by New York Knicks fans I like that
that's motivation a lot of City wants
Michael Porter but I'm ready to work I'm
ready to get the organization try to win
some games so Kevin Knox is turning the
boos into motivation which is what Terry
said you had to do exactly in a day you
gotta step between the lines you got to
play they can do it they can do all they
won't Excel they won't but you do guy
they got a place oh yeah this is a guy
who just got a performance guy that
Knicks fans didn't boo
they blew Chris tops I feel like they
booed Frankie nicotine like I feel like
they've boot everybody I mean I can't
remember a time that they didn't boo the
next day they picked they booed didn't
you a Gallinari back in the day they
probably booed Jordan Hill probably
right yeah Knicks fans always have
there's always like one guy that they've
like locked in on like with porzingis I
think like I think Knicks fans wanted
mudiay which no man has been credit that
they don't just do whatever the fanbase
wants they go after the guy I mean are
we going this far they want the top guy
every other are we going as far back as
Patrick Ewing as the last guy that
Knicks fans didn't boo I mean again
based on their draft history maybe
that's not Ross lived in New York my
entire life I can't remember a guy that
that was an obvious pick that all the
fans wanted in management actually
pulled the trigger on that guy I can't
remember one man it's tough being the
next fan this is the thing it gets
skewed because first of all draft has
been held in New York forever right so
you know it's gonna be filled with
Knicks fans so there's going to be more
reaction on the Knicks pick than any
other pick anyway just by virtue of it
being here and on top of that their New
Yorker
over the over the years they traded a
lot of first rounders yes finally get
that pick after one on the booty games
it's nice alright so we're gonna do the
Lakers pick then the Sixers pick and
then Terry Rozier is going to do the
Celtics pick in two picks
so get ready he knows he knew like three
hours ago that's how I already know
alright so your new teammates Miss Cleo
Terry Rozier will be giving you a free
tarot card reading until then
25th pick the Lakers we're gonna move
honor
not to be confused with Mwanga nor its
move ogner d vincenzo we all know that
the Los Angeles Lakers fans guys I get
it you're more focused on LeBron Paul
George and and all the rest coming to
your team but mo vogner from Michigan we
saw him in their tournament run what
kind of a big guy are they getting out
of this guy he is the prototypical
stretch big guy I know you're seeing and
put the ball in the basket around the
rim right now but his calling card in
the NBA is pick and pop stretched the
floor over 39% from downtown in both
years at Michigan has really good
footwork actually he's not a great
athlete now the blow by type guy he's
gonna explode past us up the rim but
good footwork off the dribble can't
attack a closeout question is County
rebound County defend county pass all
right
so he goes 25 this is the lowest player
to have gone off your big board you had
him listed at 38 so with that in mind
what grade are you given for the Lakers
taking about 25 I'm gonna give it to be
because I do like his fit for what they
need they need a center and somebody who
can step outside and knock down shots
and I think vogner sticks in the league
for a long time because of that one
skill now he's not a very good defender
he's not a big-time rebounder and he's
not a passer but he's a very competitive
very passionate kid the city is gonna
really enjoy him particularly if he
continues to shoot the way he did the
past couple years
alright mo Vagner again we have no idea
who was gonna be on the Lakers next year
but this could be a piece that joins
them vogner the pick for the Lakers at
25
okay so the Sixers pick is in I don't
know if it's in but it's up to the
Sixers man I am I'm genuinely excited
about the Celtics Sixers rivalry because
I don't know if you remember the 80s I
don't even think you were born yet but
the 80s of these Celtics Sixers and
Lakers and that like kind of trio was so
awesome and I'm just happy the Sixers
and relevant again I feel like Boston's
always kind of been there and I'm sure
you remember that time like 83 Sixers
was the one team I grew up on knowing
that they were good now these these
rivalries they kind of you know they
they fizzled at times and you go through
these long droughts in the NBA I'm not
sure we actually have like I hope sorry
like this is what we're seeing the
beginnings of because you guys had a
pretty feisty series I hope we're seeing
the beginnings of that that that lasts
for years because right now honestly
aside from Cavs Warriors being in four
straight finals what what real rivalry
is there you know we talked about Lakers
Celtics okay it finally it came back for
a few years there but that's already
been eight years ago now yes that's died
that's gone again the Lakers it's been
been irrelevant we don't have one so you
know you know by all means fired up
against them beat again yeah we would
love that all right so the Sixers pick
is in but Jesse why don't you come in
here Terry I want you to write down who
you think the Celtics are gonna be
taking it 27 and let's see if you have a
secret like we won't look like we'll
just we'll just hang you some options
yes okay here you go you've got the list
here is the list here are the list of
the guys either if they're not crossed
out they're still available that's the
position I'm due this week you're gonna
call Danny Ainge
all right face time Danny Ainge see if
he is yeah let's see it
ask him if he's trading you tonight
don't well yeah that would be good to
know to facetiming Danny Ainge live on
Facebook and YouTube right here on
bleacher report tell them that I said hi
we go back a long way me and the Ainge
guy we got an ace peak you are after the
Sixers pics so I think you're on the
clock I can call them right now in this
person oh my god
thinks we got the next pick right six
are going right now all right he's
literally AC Danny Ainge why I got does
it see if you don't answer it's gonna
look bad no it's not I can't believe
you're doing he busy if you don't answer
he's busy yeah he's probably got a draft
pick to make he might be worried to see
a call coming from you and yeah Danny it
says who is gonna be you know I'd be I
didn't really know who is gonna be sorry
you know the end little inside scoop try
to find out right now okay you don't
really want to give me an inside scoop I
understand okay okay
gotcha you know I just wanted to I just
wanted to call it message you a little
bit evil you know all right mama talk to
you be safe yep Bob Williams I'm gonna
go Bob I think I think we just made some
kind of history there I'm not sure what
kind of history he was married so Robert
Williams the center there's a rubber one
yeah same thing Robert I can't hold on
time out we need to live in this for a
second Robert Williams was purchased you
had him at 18 you literally talked about
how he is the big guy rim protector I
look at your team you guys need a big
guy and a rim protector and that shows
you that Terry is a really good
relationship with Danny Ainge exactly I
hope that this didn't ruin that
relationship not never and watch
apparently has just confirmed that there
got it well he has confirmed that they
are tantalized by Robert Williams I
think you got some recruit no you're a
savage I am kind of
I'm proud of you man look at you you've
earned your paycheck
but we don't know who the team that will
win the East the Sixers took a twenty
six so let's go to master in June with
the real East Conference Chamber 26 the
Sixers of taking Landry shamit we
already knew about some pics oh I don't
know you that is a Landry Shem it
alright so what I can't believe you just
did that you're the head
let's do did you already know I just
thought Bob Williams Barbara Williams
that was incredible so I have now
experiencing some amazing moments on
bleacher report live one you calling
Danny Ainge two Simms calling Kyle
Shanahan during the draft two years ago
that was great and he picked up all
right so you've given it so Landry how
do I pronounce this man it chamb it from
Wichita State now the lowest player
that's gone off your board I don't
really care that was awesome Robert
Williams game bring that super cool
camera over here Landry Shannon is now
the newest Philadelphia 76er god that
was awesome after a trade of the earlier
picked the Sixers stand pat at 26 and
they take Landry Shannon out of Wichita
State loss give me and all the Sixers
fans the goods I thought it was a little
bit of a reach he was much lower on my
board but a very mature versatile player
he's six four he played point guard for
Wichita State but was actually the most
efficient a spot-up player in all of
college basketball in terms of points
per possession one of the best shooters
in the country he's not an explosive
athlete doesn't blow by guys but has a
great feel for the game a very sound
passer doesn't turn the ball over too
much he's gonna be a nice game manager I
guess that's what they're looking for in
their second unit how was he defensively
what's the grade the grade is a c-plus
because I think I'm looking down at the
board and I'm seeing some guys who I
just think are clearly better prospects
but who am I to say the chyme it can't
play in the league he can't contribute
he's going to do a little bit of
everything as a role
player a pastor a knockdown shooter he's
probably not going to be a plus defender
but I think he could hold his own and
maybe even got both of those backcourt
positions because of his size all right
so it seems like the six are taking two
guys in the six four six six he's more
of a shooter the earlier pigs a year
more of an athlete we'll see if they can
blend together and the Sixers continue
to grow with their young core in the
Eastern Conference I want to say this
right now I've always appreciated you
I've always liked you that was one of
the most baller things that I've ever
[ __ ] seen and I'm dropping an f-bomb
for effect because I appreciate you I
mean talk about how Hrbek I'm still
giddy that was great I was nervous I was
nervous I was worried Danny might say
like one thing too many that shouldn't
be said possibly on a live broadcast but
you know yeah see what he said though
the first thing he said he always joking
around with me were getting another
point guard to replace you I felt like
where he was because you know Danny go
missing for like a week or two and he
Blake where you been at he was like yeah
went to go find a point guard that's
better than you and it replaced you so
you know you're always joking around
with that so you know that's how you
started off but let's see not a lot of
players can have that kind of so he's
like a real cool guy like he's a real
cool guy you know he makes everybody
feel comfortable you know he interact
with everybody I feel like if you got a
golfer got a golf club with golf ball in
front of you you follow that's his
that's his that's his own that's new
golf you're not a golfer a few paws down
if you could get pants that match that
shirt and went golfing with Danny I
would make his day
so he picked up obviously the middle to
draft a time that's very busy right as
he's about to make the pick so obviously
I mean I'm sure one of his assistants is
making the pick for him but like if he'd
pick up then he'll probably pick up any
time I mean is that you got you got
friends around the league do you think
it's unusual for you know a guy to just
be able to like buzz the GM anytime even
on a busy night and just have him pick
up and does that like that must make you
feel pretty that's really hard to think
of I wouldn't even think
nobody even trying to get in contact
with a gym two picks before they
actually go so you know but it's just so
just this what kind of guy he is I
interact with his with his players how
the strong relationship we have stuff
like that I really didn't expect him to
pick up you know all right in an another
time during the season if there were the
last couple of seasons if there was a
point where you just like you were
whatever it might have been going
through a rough time right in his
terrible if you had a rough patch
have you had one of those moments where
you called him because you actually did
need him for something because stuff was
going on or you're trying to sort out
you know whatever it was career-wise or
off the court no not really not really
not really but you he basically let you
know he's a guy that's there if you need
them yeah he's easy to call understands
cuz he's a guy he's a gym buddy he
understand he's he's a guy that played
in the league so he knows what goes with
this what happens with you know what
comes with it so it's a guy that's
easier to talk to versus other gyms only
all right so we're gonna break it down
but before we do I want to show you
Robert Williams film and take a look at
some of the clips and then I want you to
give the grade for the pic give me pigs
Robert Williams yes again momentarily Oh
big-time athlete one of the best in the
draft so Terry Rozier soaking it in
watching some highlights seeing some
downtown slams oh you get you're getting
a rim protector there I think one day
Danny Ainge don't miss ya know his
talent he liked guys he'd like tough
guys he'd like guys is gonna stick their
neck out there so this is the big pick
for us is huge so Terry Rozier is great
after watching some of those highlights
what do you think of this pick at 27 I
gonna do was CBS Sports did to me I'm
gonna give him b-plus a b-plus I thought
you're gonna imitate Plus no beefless
he's gonna earn he got he got our net a
for me you got to come in from first
date yeah I will be here you know some
of the practices and some early yeah
think he had deserved that a but I give
them a beaut so all four of us are gonna
be in this video
we're gonna do the video together
alright so we're gonna start over we're
all this video because Terry you are
gosh you're a freaking legend I still
can't believe it alright let's start the
video Robert Williams the grade for
Boston Celtics at 27 all right Celtics
Terry Rozier his twitter is blowing up
because they just took Robert Williams
out of Texas A&M what we're gonna do
Jonathan Wasserman's gonna break down
who he is and terror rose he was gonna
chime in what do you think I'll do it
really fast he is a Clint capela tight
big guy above the rim big-time leaper a
shot blocker a lob catcher a finisher
and a rebounder he's limited skill wise
but that's not what the Boston Celtics
are gonna ask him to do they're gonna
ask them to catch finish dunk rebound
and block shots alright so you just
watch the fellow for Terry this is your
future teammate what did you see what
excites you you know just him just being
a president side nothing the ball and
things like that it's a great we're
gonna need that for the other side and
you know we're gonna make it work is
it's gonna be great just to have them
step on step on the organization from
this first day and I was just you know
having a lot of fun and compete and
there's gonna be exciting to see what he
brings to this they're gonna see what he
does in Vegas right away oh yeah right
away I would be on the right away of him
beer right away his and you were say
before Danny Ainge doesn't mess and you
don't miss so he knows something and we
got his back and we take off from here
awesome Beck you know what the Celtics
are this roster had a zip it in look
they're not a lot of team needs here the
first thing I wrote down about needs for
them this year was none but back up big
and a certainly an athletic one who's a
shot blocker a rim protector certainly a
guy who you can get into that big man
rotation I mean now Horford brings a lot
to the table but you don't think of him
as that that overpowering rim protector
shots water with the length and the
leaping ability that we just saw so I
think he's a nice person to put in that
mix they don't need him right away
obviously this is a stacked roster but
yeah
phenomenal pick wass your grade for
Robert Williams
27 the Celtics hey - this is a
borderline lottery town that Ainge hits
on again yeah I mean at the fact that we
went to Boston is gonna be great for
from Rob Williams as well so a - no
doubt alright so that is the wasp in
grade and the terror rose year great for
Robert Williams that I already gave
gonna be plus but you said he has to
earn the a he earned a B+ is right there
on the day so you know come in do what
you got to do I get a Austin teros year
will be the teacher he'll be the tutor
he'll be the mentor Robert Williams
welcome to class it is in session Danny
Ainge right on be our live letting
everybody know Robert Williams could be
a future big man for bossed welcome baby
we'll have a lot of fun don't clap you
feel successful I'm excited alright so
the Warriors were 28th Nets 29th Atlanta
30th June do you want to catch us up
because I know we were talking a lot
there at number 29 the Warriors are
selecting Jacob Evans oh right sorry
number 28 overall you are dressed up to
tweet not just me messing up well does
that you're messing up - so what did
woods mess up he said it was a 29th pick
and then I read it because of a
anchorman robot yeah what was the
verbage that was use lock on so he's
he's tampering it down a little bit yeah
he's getting tired there's the time it
was escalating like it was a romance
novel and now he's bringing it back down
he's ready a woge romance novel would be
super dry he then looked at her and said
I love you and then happily ever end
those paper bags they bite the airport
it would be a hundred and forty
characters or less I don't know 280 oh
excuse me excuse me I forgot big changes
such a 2015 joke now geez alright so
this kid went to Cincinnati yeah man I
don't do the I don't know what he is I
don't know who he is
I'm just curious I really don't know
anything but he's he's on the Warriors
so I'm going
want to know how he fits in was it a
point of need and then also if you're a
big fan I tweeted out a couple days ago
Jacob Evans had a great workout from
what I heard then he is the perfect fit
obviously who's not a good fit and
golden state for what they need it's
just like the Jordan Belle a guy who can
come in and play to his strengths not
have to do things he can't cool hand
masterful video big big hit big win damn
again do the words ever not hit it's
coming off yet another World
Championship Warriors fans
congratulations the draft has seemingly
just a ceremony to coronate you Jacob
Evans Cincinnati how does he fit in fits
him perfectly
he shoots threes what a surprise you
know he does a little bit of everything
he doesn't have one specialty skill
which is probably why he slipped and if
you look at his numbers you're wondering
why as a first-round pick but this is a
guy who passes the eye test and you kind
of forget about the stats very tough kid
six six guards multiple positions shoots
threes secondary playmaker gets downhill
attacks not great at creating his own
shot but a glue guy who's gonna be the
glue between the star players in Golden
State know some people kind of compare
him to like a Courtney Lee type you had
him going right around here what grade
do you get for the Warriors taking about
28 I believe I gave it a name - because
of the fit and he may not scream upside
he's not a crazy athlete he's not a
crazy scorer but that's not what Golden
State needs he needs a guy who can play
between the star players move the ball
knock down open shots give you defensive
toughness and he does all three awesome
warriors another title another draft in
which doubt the wasserman ghost how did
they get this guy Jacob Evans enjoy
joining a team that seemingly will win
another championship next season unless
the Sixers beat them
what is it like being on a team that's
getting so much hype right now like the
Celtics everyone is like Kyrie and
Hayward joining you guys like can you
feel that excitement building right now
yeah I mean I mean it's great to hear
about it
you know obviously last summer we didn't
know you know I was different but at the
same time you still is still got a whole
season ahead of us so I think we all got
one goal when we come in a training camp
and you know it's gonna be interesting
to see what happens but it's gonna be a
lot of fun it's good to have a high bar
it's always good to have it and you know
we a great organization we're just
looking to have some fun so we'll see
what happens
yeah you'll keep the focus who can beat
the Sixers results every time we play
them so it's gonna be very exciting oh
great
are you you're going to Vegas again yeah
beater I didn't know that you were still
gonna be playing than that might play oh
okay like guys are like one year and
they're out maybe two years they used to
be like like guys like like way back and
they bow out la oh la works didn't the
guy had like a 15 year career whatever
he went to summer league every year they
Robbins doesn't how many MVP yeah nayee
like retarders years he's a legend there
yeah well look man it's Vegas again a
now you're sure yes master June when you
got for us guys whoa is tweeting the
Nets are discussing several trade
possibilities with the 29th pick and as
you can see from this photo shop I can't
lie close to the juice man I ain't gonna
front account so I think one of the MVPs
of the night is Adrian Coffman arouse
key I think came up with 30 different
woge memes to immediately tweet after
every single loads bum because we knew
that the woods problems were gonna
happen but then it's up to the
second-tier guy to capitalize on the
bomb and that's what conf norske has
done I don't know if captain Russkies a
real person but he's verified on Twitter
he's got a verified account yeah so now
I'm wondering
kofi I think I believe he works for a
subpoena shoutout Kofi young cat out
here trying to do his thing
there was a smart move though that's a
very smart bless the juice man I'm
that's that's probably the best one yeah
I like I don't know what is that in
reference to Oh J to juice man call it a
break half-breed oh hey good lookin out
Terry me and our back we're not gonna
back you up there June I know that
you've been a big Brooklyn Nets fan
forever yeah waiting for the Celtics
together should be your team was built
with all their picks it was a joke I
know but I'm saying you know he was he
was confirming it okay yeah me and you
and actually have season tickets to the
Mets all day every day
it cost like five dollars run we're the
upper balcony why is lower seat so I
didn't lose Tom about five dollars a
night's game I get you a lot it will get
to a lot that's the truth at like if you
want to watch a team coming into New
York don't try to get a ticket to
Madison Square Garden go to Brooklyn get
you LeBron tickets in Brooklyn it smells
like Cologne there it's great and they
have grass on top of the roof I didn't
say you only get from Esther in June all
right so Robert Williams is off the
board that means that you're top rated
guy is the Anthony Melton after that is
jinan Moussa from Bosnia then Ellie
okobu from France
we've already had Jacob Evans off and
then Kyrie Thomas that was the guy that
you said the Sixers should have drift
he's from Creighton what do they miss
out by not going with that guy well
especially the fact that they traded me
Cal bridges who's just kind of a bigger
version of Kyrie Thomas and he's not
very creative with the ball but that's
not what he'd be asked to do at the NBA
level he's a catch and shoot get out in
transition and defend he's that
back-to-back Big East Defensive Player
of the Year you told me that the start
of the second round there could be a lot
of possible starters this is I guess the
list what are you seeing on this list
what sticks out to you about who's
available right now
Wow a lot of big names k debates D up
was the Big Ten Player of the Year like
I said before Kyrie Thomas was I thought
going to be a first-round pick
Moussa from Bosnia came over and did a
lot of workouts for teams drafting in
the 20
Mitchell Robinson is a guy who was a top
ten recruit 7-1 flies above the rim
we'll skip this year in college but in
terms of upside he's a lottery type town
I guess the day and that I also saw in
that was Jalen Brunson the Poincare to
Villanova I feel like he's a hotly
debated guy in terms of what he'll be at
the next level I wouldn't be surprised
if he's the last pick of the first round
and that's what I've had and we'll see
what happens but Brunson is a very
interesting player our let's go to our
resident Brooklyn Nets fans master in
June number 30 overall Brooklyn is gonna
check select John and Musa unfortunately
it's the 29th pick one ninth pick I
really enjoy pulling at Arian correct
yeah I want me to put you out there it
happens sometimes
alright so John on Musa from Ball Z and
you said this guy's been doing like a
ton of workouts yeah he just finished up
overseas and came over and did a bunch
of workouts for teams in the 20s and for
most of the year projected as a
first-round pick he stayed in the first
one Radia thinkin this late this is a
solid beat I see if he comes over he
just turned 19 years old so he's a
project but very productive player
overseas also I want to go before we do
this video and before we do the last
speck I want to thank everybody in the
control room I want to thank all the
camera operators Nick Gabe Jordan Alex
George Jesse for helpin out of course
master and June you guys have it Austin
Terry thank you so much for being here
Howard and wasps you guys make this
possible from Steve to mark everybody
back there to do this setup in here if
you guys don't know this is in the
bleacher report office we are right here
on the basketball court this is a big
mural that we have you want to kind of
pan out Michael Jordan's the incredible
greatness my only complaint is his left
hand is backwards and squished it's once
you see it it's really hard to unsee it
if you come back down Gabe let's show
everybody we got Rihanna
we have Spike Lee Jay Bay the immortal
Craig Sager our IP legend at Turner what
an amazing guy happen we have them up
there Jimmy gold
who opened up our house to us and we
actually had a party there during
all-star games you haven't seen Jimmy
Goldstein's house you have to see it
it's incredible here we go
did you just burp yeah that's Jimmy I
was disgusting hey go Jimmy's a super
fan you've seen it with the Hat right
yeah with the hat he's the man right now
he's the man oh yeah
Spike Lee Jack Nicholson Drake my
favorite part about today's show has
been every time that we see Howard Beck
Drake has been over his shoulder
reacting crazy so if you take Howard
Beck shot real quick just the one shot
of Howard Beck every single hot take so
you know how our back is they push a tee
of bleacher report Sabri shut up all
right so thank you everybody again if
you've been watching on Facebook live or
YouTube thank you so much you wouldn't
just something awesome happen I mean you
literally witnessed Danny Ainge answer a
face-to-face time and give us Robert
Williams pending a physical so shout out
again to Terry for making that happen
let's now go to the Nets pic and that
was John and Moosa kid from Bosnia how'd
I do there Terry thought that was pretty
smooth yeah pretty appreciate you thanks
for really contributing oh the hiccups
you gotta dig up salut that's amazing
right after this video will get Terry's
hiccups so John and Musa
Brooklyn Nets how a first-round pick
can't believe I'm saying that and
they're going out of Bosnia John and
Musa you said that this guy was all over
the place to have workouts how did he do
in those workouts of one of the Nets get
well apparently not good enough because
I don't think the teams he worked out
for it took him
having said that still first-round kid
just turn nineteen years old he is a
scorer and a very competitive to score
not a great athlete plays a little bit
hunched over as you could see yeah but
man he could put the ball in the basket
in 31 FIBA games dating back to 2014
he's averaged 25 points he scored every
single level he's played at this year in
the Adriatic League in Croatian league
finished with 21 points and one of the
Finals games we'll see if he comes over
and one of the rare NBA players whose
wingspan is less than his height yeah a
little interesting they're great for
getting him at this point at 29 I think
it's a beat I mean there's nothing super
exciting about it but at the same time
it's number 29 if you can get a role
player a rotation player kind of reminds
me of Bogdanovich actually both of them
honestly just as as a scorer as a shot
maker I don't think he's gonna defend
much but I think I could put the ball in
the basket and that's what the Brooklyn
Nets need we'll see if John and Musa can
be the Bosnian blur for the Brooklyn
Nets next season
hey buffs alone you're up I'm okay I'm
Mike Breen the problem is I only sound
good if I say Lisa Leslie so I go Lisa
Leslie puts alone it's not bad right
you're trending in love thank so much
too much toward the mic breeds your
favorite announcer what did you say I
was training to your brain is tending to
it too much toward Marv it's like that's
like a mashup well Marv I go out from
downtown Allen Iverson yes it's not bad
there we go yeah so you're Mike Breen
guy alright I just started digging my
ear Terry that means that the last pick
of the first round
dude you're hiccuping so hard right now
trying to gently I would have got rid of
you by now we are on the last pick
Atlanta and I think for the last time
we're gonna go to the the cool
of master longtime Atlanta Hawks fan all
right now and June got very young girl
again now according to Sean saranya the
Hawks are selecting Omari Spellman with
a number 30 overall pick that's my Hari
Spellman from Villanova acta left go
anova guy the first round and Terry's
handy hiccups I really how long can you
go for yeah go let's count is he cured
all right fine I don't Higgins the first
round Omari Spellman wasel's gonna break
it down do you know what grade you're
given you hope you've already given it
it's been done it's been done let's do
it let's wrap it up and that's another
one I saw that bring that camera over
here game don't get up everything please
done hiccuping Amari Spellman will now
be joining Trey Young and Kevin herder
two great shooters and we'll see if this
guy's a shooter - he was gonna know John
Ross let's break it down a very active
first round for the Atlanta Hawks three
players have gone two shooters and now
Omari Spelman from Villanova describe
this guy who are they gonna make it
three shooters that really there's a
theme here he is a big body around 250
253 pounds long arms but he shot 43 44
percent from downtown a skilled player
below the rim player but his role was
gonna be stretched for also blocked a
shot and a half for a game long arms he
I don't know how many minutes he's gonna
play right now he missed his freshman
his true freshman season this year was
his freshman season technically right
but the guy could put the ball the
basket from downtown he's skilled inside
the arc he needs to improve his
condition he's a little bit too heavy
gotcha well that could be fixed would
you become a professional and they start
working it out all the time yeah you add
him around 45 yeah so he's going at 30
but he does have a skill set that kind
of fits what they're doing right now
yeah I've got a grade do you give here
I'm giving you to be because I think
that jumper is gonna kind of carry him
at the NBA level
as long as he could be put in a role
where he can play to his strengths as a
shooter and he holds his own defensively
not just blocking shots but sliding his
feet defensively which I think he's
gonna be able to do better once he
improves his conditioning but yeah give
him give him a year in the G League and
then we'll see him again in two seasons
probably as a rotation player off the
bench young herder Spellman there is
clearly a vision here in Atlanta if you
can shoot you can be on this team the
Hawks could they become the warriors of
the south we will find out Spelman final
pick of the first round for the Hawks
don't side ivy what the Warriors in the
South before we leave I want to get a
quick shot of a master in June this is
this is stuff right away for that other
that other had to fit on there oh I
think he's just falling right now I'm
very impressed I give them all hey
though that's my great master June you
guys are awesome Howard and at loss
thank you way to hold it down you've
done that how many dress here bleachers
is my sixth one Wow
overall the amount of town that we saw
how does it compare to the other five
dress top ten very strong I don't know
how many all-stars are gonna come out
but in terms of potential you know it's
anybody's guess who actually reaches
their ceiling yes we could see multiple
all-stars in this dress we are gonna do
winners and losers later but I'm curious
for our Facebook live audience that's
still around who kind of sticks out to
you early on as one of the big winners
for today Dallas Mavericks we said it
before they took the best in my opinion
the the number one player on my board I
know he was the number one player on
their board in Lucca da judge I think
he's a great fit with the franchise next
to Dennis Smith Jr they have a terrific
backcourt now to build with they'll see
if they can add a big in free agency I'm
sure they'll be able to add Howard how
about you what's your big takeaway from
the first round assembiy a draft
I'm with Johnny wass on this one Dallas
getting Luke Don Shh is a phenomenal
pickup obviously they were in a position
when the
I began to get him but I'm also you know
I'm high on Bamba you know you guys know
like I'm not spending a ton of time yeah
John the amount of time that the
Wasserman spending on the draft but the
impressions I've gotten of Bamba just
his professionalism in his makeup and
his his just the the total physical
makeup yes what he could potentially be
for Orlando
it's like those those stand out to me
you know you can go with the obvious you
know Phoenix got the guy they wanted an
eight and and made what looks like might
be a really good deal at the expense of
your sex or spoke yes this is what it is
I'm gonna give my big winner of the
night to Terry Rozier there's not a lot
of people that will risk their life
livelihood by facetiming their GM right
before the pic and that was truly an
awesome moment and I thank you for that
do you have a message for Boston Celtics
fan them out there if you want to take a
shot one more time a Twitter finger Joel
embiid you could do that sign us off in
between your hiccups would be great yeah
I'm trying to get through AB uh we're
gonna win the championship I'm gonna say
- oh it's crazy that it's going this
long we're thinking about it's a visa
nothing less
signing out Bob Williams welcome to the
family there's a lot of great things we
expected out of you is gonna be a great
year in after the process that's all oh
I heard that and I did not like it I'm
Terry man I appreciate you dude not
again
how was a good time I appreciate it guys
thank you so much for joining us be our
Facebook live YouTube you guys have been
awesome really really appreciate you
follow us NBA coverage Instagram Twitter
Facebook we got you covered
that lamelle o ly Angelo meme yeah it's
gonna take over the Internet love you
guys talk to you soon on the lef koe man
hollering at you see you soon
[Music]
[Music]